les enjeux des pollutions atmosphériques
et aquatiques sont relativement bien
identifiés ainsi que leurs effets sur la
santé humaine et les manière d'agir pour
réduire les pressions issues des
activités humaines on ne peut pas en
dire autant des sols ils ne font pas
l'objet d'une attention cituyenne aussi
forte il forme pourtant un bien précieux
et fragile il faut environ un millénaire
pour la formation d' la formation d'un
seul centimètre de sol il s'agit de l'un
des écosystèmes de la biosphère
les plus riches en organismes vivants
trop souvent ils sont réduits à leur
potentiel agronomique et à leur
performance nutritive pour l'agriculture
il faut dire que cet axe central et il
est très central car 95 % de nos
aliments viennent du sol c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai jugé utile de pouvoir
élargir nos perspectives en conviant les
meilleurs spécialistes scientifiques
afin qu'il nous éclaire sur les nombreux
services écosystémiques fourni par des
sols fonctionnels et des sols en bonne
santé ils nous expliqueront en quoi les
sols ont la capacité de renforcer la
résilience des territoires je tiens très
sincèrement à remercier l'Institut
national de recherche pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et l'environnement
l'inraé dans un certain nombre de
scientifiques attachés à cette belle
maison sont présents dans le public et
mais ils ne sont pas arrivés normalement
ils étaient présents dans le public je
tiens à les pour la qualité de leur
travail et les incomparables services
scientifiques qu'ils fournissent à la
société et aux politiques que nous
sommes pour les représenter nous
accueillons Lionel
Ranjard directeur de recherche
travaillant à l'UMR agroécologique de
Dijon sur la question de la santé des
sols le vif intérêt de notre collègue
Nicole Bonnefoi la conduira très
certainement à vous poser de nombreuses
questions j'ai également souhaité que
cette table ronde inclue une séquence
juridique avec un des meilleurs
connaisseurs du droit des sols le
professeur Philippe billet directeur de
l'Institut de droit de l'environnement
de Lyon je le remercie de sa
disponibilité et de son
expertise qui contribuera
l'enrichissement des connaissances des
sénateurs sur les dernières évolutions
législatives et réglementaires non
seulement la manière dont ce droit s'est
développé depuis l'émergence de la
notion de gestion économe de l'espace
mais également sur les insuffisances
qu'il identifie au regard de la
cohérence du droit à l'environnement je
pense naturellement à la Stratégie de
Réduction du rythme de
l'artificialis l'artificialisation des
sols le fameux zan dont l'acronyme est
désormais connu de tous mais aussi à la
directive européenne en cours
d'élaboration sur la surveillance et la
résilience des sol qui part du constat
que plus de 60 % des sols européens ne
sont pas en bonne santé
et que cette situation ne fait
qu'empirer enfin nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir Chloé
Girardot vice-présidente ressources
milieu naturel biodiversité et action
foncière du conseil départemental de
Loire Atlantique ainsi que en
visionférence françois descœur
administrateur de l'Association des
Maires Ruraux de France et maire
d'anglar de salaire dans le Cantal et
qui nous livreront leur vision de
praticiens d'élus local quant au
évolutions de la loi et du Règlement
concernant l'usage des sols le Sénat
s'est beaucoup investi pour que la
logique arithmétique et descendant
duusan ne se fasse pas contre les
territoires mais avec les élus grâce à
des outils dédiés du pragmatisme et de
l'espoir avec la garantie rurale d'un
hectare par commune aujourd'hui que les
décrets ont été publiés que les règles
ont été stabilisées quelle est votre
vision pour réussir la réduction de la
artificialisation des sols tout en
développant un des projets projets qui
répondent à l'attente de nos habitants à
l'attente de nos industriels et qui
devront satisfaire aux objectifs de la
transition écologique dans une logique
vertueuse et sans opposer bien entendu
les territoires je sais que et pour le
vive sur le terrain que c'est une une
équation équation qui est
particulièrement complexe et qui
nécessitera beaucoup d'intelligence
territoriale et de créativité des élus
locaux le Sénat constituera d'ailleurs
prochainement un groupe de suivi du zan
eu ce groupe aura pour objectif de
rester à l'écoute des territoires à
l'écoute de leurs besoins de leurs
difficultés au sein duquel notre
Commission prendra et prend toute sa
place mes chers collègues avant de
laisser la parole aux intervenants et
aux sénateurs pour la série de questions
et de réponses je vous rappelle que vous
êtes toutes et tous invité àcide la
table ronde à vous rendre dans le jardin
du Luxembourg à la rencontre de des
scientifiques de l'indrae chargé de
faire des prélèvements dans les sols ces
échanges permettront de prolonger sur le
terrain ce que vous entendrez au cours
de la Table Ronde c'est-à-dire à quel
point notre commission sans mauvais jeun
mot n'est pas
horol voilà je vais donner la parole à
Guillaume
chevrolier
Guillaume je donne la parole ouais
peut-être les intervenants avant voulez
peut-être dire deux
mots allez-y comme vous voulez sinon je
donne la parole à à mes collègues
allez-y je prends je prends mon temps de
parole maintenant les 5 minutes qui dit
très bien ben écoutez allons-y merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
bonjour Merci de de cette invitation et
de la possibilité de vous présenter en
peu de temps 5 minutes la biodiversité
du sol donc j'ai prévu quelques petites
illustrations je sais je sais ah faut
que je meuble c'est ça il déjà pas mal
de choses qu' on été dit dans
l'introduction donc il va y avoir un
petit peu d'hérodite mais je vais
essayer d'aller un peu plus en
profondeur en 5 minutes
oui non ça marche pas pourant on avait
tout fait pour la compatibilité voilà
très bien parce que la biodiversité du
sol est relativement invisible donc
c'est important de de l'illustrer quand
même pour en parler voilà alors bien sûr
je je commence par les services qui sont
fournis par le sol le sol est une des
matrices environnementales des plus
stratégiques pour notre société car elle
lui fournit des services écosystémiques
fondamentaux avec trois types de
services des services de fourniture ou
d'approvisionnement des services de
régulation on en parle un peu plus en
détail et des services culturels et
récréatif alors plus précisément on peut
citer comme service le sol bien sûr
comme support de production alimentaire
monsieur le président l'a dit 95 % des
aliments viennent du sol on parle même
de 99 % avec la pêche côtière le sol
bien sûr est le support de nos
constructions et le fondement nos
infrastructures il est aussi un
réservoir et même un puit de carbone
très important et donc il est impliqué
fortement c'est un des acteurs de la
régulation du climat il est aussi
régulateur de la qualité et des flux
d'eau mais aussi bien sûr c'est ce qui
va intéresser un peu plus mon mon propos
le sol est un énorme réservoir de
biodiversité donc un habitat pour des
organismes vivants multiples et variés
et enfin le sol est aussi le support de
nos paysages et il est le garant de leur
qualité environnementale et récréative
diapositive d'après s'il vous plaît
merci alors voilà une planche
normalement en animation ça passe un peu
mieux mais là VO une planche qui vous
montre la grande diversité des
organismes présents au niveau du sol
parceque en fait c'est grâce à cette
biodiversité que le sol remplit ses
services écosystémiques on peut voir
qu'il y a une grande diversité de taille
avec des organismes très petit bactéries
et champignons ce qui est ma spécialité
je fais de l'écologie microbienne et
puis après on passe dans la faune avec
des tailles un peu supérieures des
nématodes des colambol la star des
organismes du sol qui sont les vers de
terre et puis bien sûr la plante
parcécine fait partie des organismes du
du sol et même des mammifères fouisseurs
une grande diversité de taille une
grande diversité de formme une grande
diversité de bien sûr de ressources
génétiques et de potentialité
fonctionnel et si on donne quelques
chiffres on peut dénombrer plusieurs
milliards de bactéries par gramme de sol
et dans ces plusieurs milliards il peut
y avoir plusieurs millions d'espèces la
notion d'espèces est en tout relative
pour les micro-organismes si on regarde
les vers de terre plusieurs tonnes par
hectare et d'un point de vue général en
terme d'espèces de la faune du sol par
mètre carré on peut atteindre jusqu'à
10000 espèces par mètre carré et ça ce
sont des chiffres moyens que on trouve
dans des sols naturels mais qu'on peut
aussi trouver dans des sols agricoles et
alors le chiffre a été revisité il y a
il y a quelques semaines seulement
jusqu'à récemment on disait que 25 30 %
de la biodiversité du sol se trouvait de
la biodiversité de notre planète pardon
se trouvait au niveau du sol récemment
une étude internationale montre que
c'est 59 % de la biodiversité totale de
notre planète qui se trouve au niveau du
sol diapositive suivante s'il vous
plaît alors àinra depuis une quinzaine
d'années nous avons beaucoup investi
pour essayer de faire des preuves
expérient al de l'intérêt de cette
biodiversité bien sûr cette biodiversité
c'est un patrimoine biologique mais ça
doit représenter aussi un patrimoine
fonctionnel et nous avons démontré
qu'une baisse de 30 % de la diversité
microbienne donc là je parle que des
micro-organismes bactéries et
champignons au niveau d'un sol entraîne
une baisse de 40 % de la minéralisation
de la matière organique c'est la
capacité d'un sol à transformer la
matière organique en matière minérale
donc de sa fertilité naturelle ce qui
entraîne généralement une baisse de 50 %
de la productivité végétale ce sont des
expérimentations faites en condition
contrôlées he pas au champ et alors sur
un sujet un peu plus actuel ça aussi
baisse la capacité de récupération de 15
% des plantes après une sécheresse si on
baisse de 30 % la diversité microbienne
du sol on perd 50 % de la stabilité
structurale du sol c'est-à-dire sa
capacité à résister à l'érosion à
résister au tassement aussi sa capacité
à faire un réservoir utile pour l'eau et
notamment pour les plantes et en terme
d'État sanitaire si on baisse de 30 % la
diversité microbienne du sol on va
augmenter le temps de survie de
pathogène opportuniste exogène
c'estàdire que le sol est par
aérosolidisation peut-être inoculé avec
des nouveaux organismes potentiellement
pas pathogène et si on perd 30 % de
cette diversité microbienne on va
enlever l'effet
barrière diapositive d'après s'il vous
plaît alors en France on est quand même
il faut remarquer hein un pays assez
leader assez dynamique dans l'inventaire
et la surveillance de la qualité de ses
sols notamment grâce à ce réseau de
mesure de la qualité des sols donc vous
allez visiter un site sur le jardin du
Luxembourg tout de suite après cette
réunion et ce réseau de surveillance
s'est développé il y a une vingtaine
d'années et très tôt on a décidé aussi
de caractériser la biodiversité sur les
sols à l'échelle nationale grâce à nos
outils de micro biologie moderne qui
sont des outils de biologie moléculaire
et aujourd'hui la France est un des
seuls pays à avoir des inventaires
cartographiques nationaux notamment de
la quantité de micro-organismes onelle
ceon appelle la biomasse microbienne de
la diversité bactérienne et de la
diversité des champignons alors bien sûr
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail des
carte on peut voir qu'il y a des zones
qui sont un peu plus riches que d'autres
pour des causes naturelles en premier
lieu et puis des causes un peu moins
naturelles d à certaines activité
humaine diapositive d'après s'il vous
plaît à une échelle nationale nous
sommes très dynamiques mais il faut voir
que les territoires aussi commencent à
rentrer dans cette dynamique de
caractérisation de leur sol et là je
vous donne l'exemple du territoire de
l'a urbaine de Dijon métropole qui est
donc avec un projet territoire
d'innovation du pays A3 porté par la
collectivité territoriale Dijon
métropole et cette métropole a décider
de caractériser la qualité physique
chimique et la biodiversité de ces sols
à l'échelle de l'IRE urbaine de façon
intensive et extensive donc il a des
cartes du territoire alors on retrouve
la diversité bactérienne et la quantité
de micro-organismes parce que nous
pilotons ce projet mais on a aussi les
vers de terre les odde le carbone on a
même des approches satellitaires pour
essayer de regarder les usages et de
simuler les taux de carbone bien sûr ça
va permettre à cette échelle
territoriale par rapport à l'échaînes
Natur d'avoir un impact beaucoup plus
fin une évaluation d'impact beaucoup
plus fin de l'usage des sols urbains et
agricole on a aussi investigué les sols
urbains de faire un référential
territorial de la qualité des sols et
tout ceci doit permettre bien sûr de
mener la transition écologique du
territoire voire même la transition
alimentaire et puis surtout d'articuler
la ville et plus largement les activités
humaines autour des sols en rentrant ces
notions de qualité des sols de santé des
sols au niveau des scottes des PLU et
même du prix du
foncier diapositive d'après s'il vous
plaît pour finir et puis comme c'est
Noël je vais faire un petit peu de de
promotion et je vous ai même amené des
exemplaires on pour appeler ça le petit
livre bleu ou les petits livre bleu grâ
au résultat du rmqs accumulé nous avons
voulu aussi indépendamment des
valorisations académiques faire des
atlases naturalistes à destination du
grand public des usagers des sols des
agriculteurs des politiques publiques
donc en 2018 nous avons sorti l'Atlas
français des bactéries du sol j'en ai
amené deux exemplaires pour pour le
Sénat et en 2024 début 2024 nous allons
sortir le pendant sur les champignons du
sol voilà merci de votre attention
j'espère que j'ai tenu le le temps et
non pas de problème on n pas calculé
mais vous êtes dans le temps il pas de
sou qui veut prendre la
parole
allez-y oui bonjour Mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs merci de
m'avoir invité à intervenir donc moi je
suisé gerérardo moitier je suis
vice-présidente du département de Loire
Atlantique en charge des ressources
milieux naturel biodiversité et action
foncière et donc j'avais davantage
compris qu'il s'agissait de parler du
rapport à la santé des sols en tant
qu'élu que concrètement les enjeux de la
mise en œuvre du zan donc j'ai je vais
essayer de de recorriger un petit peu
mon intervention mais du coup peut-être
que ça correspondra pas exactement à
votre attente donc d'abord pour dire que
en Loire Atlantique c'est un département
qui a beaucoup travaillé sur la question
de la zéro artificial a nette dans le
précédent mandat avant même la loi
climat et
résilience l'ensemble des élus avaent
voté à l'unanimité une délibération pour
le zéro artificialisation net et il y
avait eu un gros travail de
sensibilisation des élus du du
territoire qui nous a permis peut-être
de nous saisir un peu plus rapidement de
de cette question on est aussi lauréa
d'un appel à manifestation d'intérêt de
de laad pour travailler
avec un Scott et deux Inter communalité
et le département à une expérimentation
sur les enjeux de la mise en œuvre du
zan qui démarre tout juste avec
l'objectif de partager les connaissances
et les enseignements sur sur les
difficultés et dont on pourra évidemment
rendre compte mais le travail en est
assez début on travaille notamment sur
la dimension aussi sur la dimension mode
de vie avec des sociologues pour
comprendre ce que ça veut dire dans le
mode d'habiter le territoire avec un
volet citoyen et démarche citoyenne euh
évidemment la l'aspect soutien au cœur
de bourg à la revitalisation des Bours
de communes qui s'articulle pleinement
avec la politique zan qui est mobilisée
et puis le une politique départementale
qui va aller bah sout faire faire
beaucoup d'animation territorial pour
pouvoir promouvoir les outils comme
l'établissement public foncier le CAUE
les agences d'urbanisme on va être assez
volontariste dans les avis qu'on donne
en tant que personne publique associé
sur les avis fonciers ou dans les avis
qu'on peut rendre au niveau de la
commission d'aménagement commercial et
on on organise aussi des événements des
tables rondes pour sensibiliser à la
question avec notamment des aussi des
interventions par exemple de l'Agence de
l'eau pour comprendre les liens pourquoi
on le fait les liens avec l'eau et une
démarche peut-être aussi un peu
scientifique pour se rappeler quels sont
les enjeux derrière quelque chose qui
peut apparaître comme une
contrainte voilà pour pour pour la ce
qu'on fait puisqu'il était posé la
question des enseignements enfin des des
solutions pour réussir donc j'ai
évoquéis comment on peut le faire le
fait en comprendre pourquoi on le fait
être capable de saisir des outils
disponibles sur le territoire le portage
foncier les les les les plans guides et
cetera l'enjeu de la solidarité entre
les territoires les modes d'aménagement
la densification des usages dans nos
bâtiments euh des enjeux aussi mais qui
sont pas au niveau départemental mais
qui font partie de la solution mais qui
ont besoin d'être soutenus c'est des
enjeux de la fiscalité pour que les
modes d'aménagement les plus vertueux
puissent avoir un modèle économique donc
donc on a tout un panel de de solutions
et d'actions qui vise à à rendre
effective cette mise en œuvre du Zéro
artificialisation net je vais passer
maintenant sur la question de la la
santé des sols en tant que tel d'abord
pour vous dire que il y a un constat
d'un manque de de connaissance qui est
flagrant on le voit par exemple beaucoup
d'élus confondent l'artificialisation et
l'imperméabilisation euh ça c'est très
très courant et ça a été évoqué dans la
précédation présentation précédente
finalement euh c'est quoi un sol entre
guillemets à quoi ça sert et toutes ces
fonctionnalités euh sont assez peu connu
euh même si on voit que avec la loisane
on a remis un éclairage très fort mais
euh qui euh qui est plus sur euh une
approche de stock en fait quel est mon
stock quelles sont mes réserves de de
foncier et le sol est vu comme
indépendamment de l'agriculture
évidemment euh comme une ressource à
aménager comme un espace d'amén
aménagement avec une entrée qui va être
exclusive enfin quasiment exclusivement
sur les enjeux réglementaires notamment
les zones humides les espèces mais par
exemple ce qu'on vient de d'évoquer sur
la question des bactéries du sol de sa
richesse la séquestration du carbone est
beaucoup moins pris en compte et est
connu et maîtrisé en fait eu et et donc
bah ça ça s'explique aussi derrière sur
peut-être une moindre prise en compte
dans nos politiques publiques et aussi
un un angle qui est peut-être moins pris
en compte et et et sur lesqueles je peux
peut-être dire qu'on a des craintes
c'est la question des pollutions alors
on a l'exemple des friches industriel à
dépolluer avec les coûts que ça génère
mais on a aussi toute la pollution
chimique qui peut être dans les sols on
le voit sur nos captage d'eau potable on
a des coûts très forts sur la
dépollution liée aux intrans chimiques
agricoles qu'est-ce qu'on va qu'est-ce
qu'on a dans nos sols est-ce que on va
avoir aussi là des des enjeux de
politique euh fort comment on on on
arrive à promouvoir certains types
d'agriculture qui vont protéger cette
vie euh bactériologique notamment qui
qui qui renforce la résilience et cetera
c'est des c'est des discussions qui ont
euh peut-être pas suffisamment lieu et
du coup aussi pour dire que euh on a un
besoin de davantage de cadrage dans nos
politiques publiques je vais donner
quelques exemples euh on a un fond pour
renaturer au département un fond de
renaturation mais euh quel arbitrage on
va faire entre je vais investir de
l'argent dans pour renaturer un endroit
où finalement on va pouvoir regagner
très peu de fonctionnalité écologique
parce que la zone a déjà été très abîmée
plutôt que renaturer un autre espace
comment comment on fait ces arbitrages
comment on cartographie ça c'est aussi
l'exemple on est on y est confronté sur
la mise en place des des parcs
photovoltaïques sur d'anciennees friche
est-ce que finalement il faut aller sur
un retour à l'usage agricole ou est-ce
que c'est plutôt on peut dire que ces
terres elles sont perdues pour l'usage
agricole et qu'on va mettre du
photovoltaïque mais comment on juge
finalement de de ces terres toute la
problématique des des carrières sur les
types d'aménagement qu'on va utiliser
par exemple pour nos pistes cyclables
lesquels sont les plus vertueux par
rapport aux enjeux de protection des
sols donc en fait on a dans de très
nombreuses politiques publiques cette
question des sols qui revient avec pas
mal d'inconnus et puis un enjeu de
cohérence générale sur nos politiques
publiques où on va par d'un côté
renaturé et de l'autre côté on voit
qu'on perd 4 450 km de haie chaque année
en loireatl tique donc on on a voilà on
a parfois un besoin de finalement
prioriser là où l'effort aura peut-être
le plus de de vertu euh voilà je vais
passer assez vite juste bah pour
conclure dire que il y a peut-être
quelques éléments qui qui semblent
ressortir de de cette approche de cette
expérience que que j'ai moi en tant que
en tant qu'élu à travers le le prisme
des politiques et de l'action du
département de Loire Atlantique c'est
que bah je pense qu'il y a une attente
vraiment sur ce sujet de la la santé des
des sols que on a vraiment besoin de de
formation que l'approche one health sur
la santé devrait être beaucoup plus
connecté à l'enjeu des sols et de l'eau
et des pratiques agricoles euh ce qui
n'est pas assez le le cas aujourd'hui
euh je pense un enjeu vraiment de
capitaliser sur la politique de l'eau
quand on fait des contrats territoriaux
haut pour regagner les la fonctionnalité
de nos bass inversant quelque part on
travaille aussi la la qualité des sols
et donc s'appuyer sur la politique de
l'eau pour travailler les sols parce que
c'est éminemment lié et serait vraiment
pertinent et aussi ça a été dit
l'intégrer dans nos politiques
d'urbanisme davantage on a encore pas
mal de levier à travers nos nos outils
d'urbanisme de planification et cetera
pour prendre davantage cette
problématique en compte voilà merci de
m'avoir écouté un grand merci je je vais
passer la la parole au professeur
Philippe billet et puis après à François
des cœur en visio que je remercie mon
joint à nos
travaux bien merci monsieur monsieur le
sénateur mesdames et sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs donc 5 minutes
brièvement pour résumer une vie du sol
vue du droit c'est bien peu euh je l'ai
appelé comme tel si on veut le
rechercher dans la réglementation
unearlaisienne du droit en fait vous
n'avez absolument aucune définition
formelle du sol la première qui apparaît
n'apparaît qu'en 2010 en plus dans une
directive européenne sur les émissions
industrielles qui va définir le sol mais
uniquement comme élément de référence
sur la remise en l'état d'un sol donc on
s'intéresse principalement à un sol un
sol pollué en fait lorsqu'on va le
rechercher dans la réglementation on le
trouve sous diverses dénominations sol
terre terre territoire fond très fond
surface mais comme vous l'a expliqué
Lionel rangeard toujours sous une
approche éminemment fonctionnelle c'est
le seul support support de culture
support de construction c'est le sol qui
est filtre production d'eau potable
notamment avec les périmètres de
protection des captages le sol qui est
vecteur de risque c'est essentiellement
la vision que l'on en a enendroit de
l'environnement ce sont les soluls
pollués et puis enfin récemment et qui
cache un peu l'ensemble de ces
fonctionnalités c'est le sol comme
élément de stockage le sol comme puits
puit de carbone et en fait dans aucun
texte on ne prend en compte de façon
explicite sa qualité de milieu naturel
ou même sa naturalité contrairement à
l'air ou à l'eau qui sont traités à part
dans le code de l'environnement et de
fait lorsqu'on s'intéresse au code de
l'environnement qui a priori un code
dédié vous n'avez pas de auti des milieu
physique rien sur le sol vous avez les
eaux milieux aquatiques et marins d'un
côté vous avez l'air et l'atmosphère de
l'autre alors CT vous me direz la loi
biodiversité du 8 2016 a rajouté un
chapitre sol et sous-sol mais c'est
seulement pour les sols malades alors
qu'on se serait attendu à ce qu'on ait
une une mise en œuvre effective
d'éléments relatifs au sol et il se
cache encore plus si on s'attache à ce
qui constitue le patrimoine commun de la
nation l'article 1110 C1 du code de
l'environnement qui vise un certain
nombre d'éléments qui va même d'ailleurs
jusqu'à considérer que les sons et les
odeurs qui caractérise les milieux font
partie du patrimoine commun de la nation
le sol n'y est pas il est caché dans un
souspagraphe les processus biologiques
les sols et la giversité concour à la
constitution du patrimoine commun donc
il n'est pas patrimoine commun En tant
que tel ce qui on pourra en rediscuter
par rapport à des propositions de loi
récentes sont lié essentiellement à la
peur qu'on pourrait avoir d'une
nationalisation du sol en le faisant
patrimoine commun alors que ça a une
toute autre signification on verra qu'on
peut avoir des formulations qui sera un
peu plus on dira rassurante alors on le
trouve heureusement sous certaines
protection ponctuelles puisque tout ce
qui est parcs nationaux réserves
naturelle zone humide vous avez le mot
sol qui intervient comme élément de
protection les études d'impact et
évaluation environnementale intègrent le
sol mais la plupart du temps
d'expérience est essentiellement le sol
surfasscique donc dans le quantitatif et
pas dans le qualitatif qui est pris en
compte vous avez également tous les
dispositifs de lutte contre l'érosion
des sols pour protéger le bon état des
eaux et la lutte contre l'artifici
ationtion on n' pas véritablement non
plus qui aurait pu contraindre la France
à avoir une réglementation spécifique de
convention internationale sur le sol
bien sûr on trouve dans le cas de la
Convention alpine notamment son
protocole
1998 une protocole sur la le la
protection des sols qui impose mais
c'est uniquement le sol alpin qui soit
préservé de façon durable en vue de
sauvegarder son utilisation mais son
utilisation est essentiellement à des
fins touristiques et d'urbanisation vous
avez également le Partenariat mondial
pour les sollds de la faao de 2013 et
qui vise la sécurité alimentaire et puis
comme vous le savez désormais la l'Année
internationale des sols 2015 avec sa
journée mondiale tous les 5 décembre de
chaque année et qui sont organisé en
France par l'Association française pour
l'étude du sol le droit communautaire
droit de l'Union vous n'avez pas de
compétence explicite donc on a une
approche communautaire qui est
extrêmement limitée comme je vous l'ai
dit la protection des sols n'intervient
que lorsqu'on est dans le cadre de la la
pollution industrielle et le seul cas
que j'ai pu repérer où le sol était
explicitement pris en compte en matière
d'urbanisme notamment c'était la
première directive CVO jusqu'à la cvzo 3
en matière d'urbanisation
périindustrielle autour des sites
industriels donc pour limité cette
urbanisation mais le sol n'apparaît pas
véritablement en tant que tel on en
trouve également des traces dans
l'écoconditionnalité des ades agricole
avec la la nouvelle pâack sur les aides
en faveur notamment de l'environnement
pour la rétention du carbone par les sol
l'amélioration de leur résilience on en
trouve également dans les bonnes
conditions agricoles et
environnementales pour le stockage de
nouveau du carbone donc toujours le lien
avec le le climat imposant des maintiens
d'enherbement des sols des limitations
de l'érosion par exemple mais vous
n'avez pas de texte fédérateur au niveau
de l'Union vous le savez vous aviez une
projet de directive cadre en 2006 qui a
échoué notamment du fait de l'opposition
de la France sur ce sur ce caractère et
nous avons désormais un nouveau projet
en cours de discussion euh dans le
casadre de ce qu'on appelle la stratégie
de l'Union européenne pour les sols à
l'horizon 2030 et vous avez un un projet
de de directive dans dans ce cadre-là
mais qui vise essentiellement euh la
question de la santé des sols avec un
passeport de santé pour les sols
l'introduction d'un certificat dans le
cadre des transactions foncières le
suivi euh de l'artificialisation des
sols vous avez tous des dispositifs de
monitoring ceci euh est comment dire
constituer des espèces de district de
façon à déterminer des qualités de sol
particulières pour qu'on ait une
uniformisation en tout cas de la
politique de protection des sols à
l'échelon à l'échelon communautaire
l'essentiel étant d'arriver à ce que
l'on appelle une gestion durableable des
sols notamment via l'agriculture
régénératrice donc le lien nécessaire à
effectuer avec toute la politique
agricole dans ce cadre-là lorsqu'on est
en matière de droit de l'environnement
franco-français mais qui dépend
essentiellement de la transposition de
la directive 2004 35 sur la
responsabilité environnementale c'est le
seul cas où on va apparaître les
services écosystémiques des sols euh
puisque le cas de responsabilité
environnementale donc qui va conduire le
préfet notamment à intervenir pour
préserver les sols par des mesures de de
de sanction administrative va viser
notamment l'introduction directe ou
indirecte en surface et dans le sol de
substance et autres éléments qui créent
un risque d'atteinte mais c'est un
risque d'atteinte grave à la santé par
le sol donc ce n'est pas le sol en tant
que tel qui est protégé mais la santé
humaine via les atteintes au sol le seul
cas où le sol est totalement pris en
compte c'est le fait que vous pourriez
avoir des atteintes au servicees
écosystémiqu rendu par les sols et la
position du préfet sera de restaurer
ceci ce qui est intéressant c'est que le
texte contrairement à beaucoup d'autres
textes en matière de responsabilité va
imposer une
responsabilité avec une restauration
essentiellement en nature avec un
certain nombre d'éléments de gradation
de restauration dont on pourra reparler
qui de mon point de vue manque assez
singulièrement dans la politique zan
vous avez toute une s'agissant de santé
des sols toute une politique de de de
réhabilitation des sols pollués qui
avaient été misise en place par la loi
allure de de de 2014 avec des des
objectifs de restauration de
réhabilitation
post-explloitation d'installation classé
vous avez toute une batterie de poli
spéciale poli spéciale installation
classée poli spéciale déchets poli
spéciale sol pollué donc autant
d'éléments qui portent atteinte à la
santé du sol et qui laissent le préfet
et le maire en première ligne avec des
moyens relativement limités pour pouvoir
agir dans ce cadrelà reste le code sur
lequel le sol est le plus présent c'est
le droit de l'urbanisme le code de
l'urbanisme avec avant 2016 on avait un
principe d'économie des sols et qui
désormais n'est plus qu'un principe de
d'économie des des des espaces naturels
qui doivent être gérés de de façon de
façon économe avec un certain nombre de
de protections ponctuel qu'on peut
retrouver notamment dans la protection
des espaces agricoles pour éviter ce
qu'on appelle les l'étalement
l'étalement urbain un certain nombre
d'objectifs de protection doivent
figurer dans les les rapports de
présentation des SCOD dans les rapports
de présentation des PLU vous avez des
évaluations récurrentes s'agissant des
questions de de de densification et
surtout de lutte contre
l'artificialisation puisque la loi alure
a supprimé un certain nombre de
dispositions qui justement favorisaient
celle-ci alors le dernier élément le
dernier avatar en date dans ce ce cadre
là de lutte contre l'artificialisation
c'est comme vous le savez le zan donc le
zéro artificialisation nette alors qu'il
y a beaucoup qui a beaucoup gêner les
les les les les les écologues s'agissant
du caractère net puisque c'est un bilan
avec comme vous le savez une
compensation entre des atteintes et une
une réhabilitation tout en sachant qu'on
s'interroge aussi mais on pour en
reparler d'un point de vue scientifique
sur ce qu'on appelle effectivement
réhabilitation réhabilitation des sols
ça présente quand même au-delà de tous
ces défauts dont on pourra en reparler
un intérêt pour le recyclage foncier et
la remise en l'état des sols ça présente
un intérêt pour un retour à la
fonctionnalité des sols mais euh le
texte donne une prime au mauvis élèves
dans la mesure où on prend comme
référence les artificialisations des
années antérieures donc ceux qui ont le
plus artificialisé se retrouve avec le
plus de capacité d'artificialisation
plus tard pose le problème également du
retour effectif à la fonctionnalité
puisque on va avoir une
artificialisation immédiate du sol avec
une réhabilitation qui peut dans son en
effectivité prendre plusieurs plusieurs
années voir plusieurs plusieurs
décennies alors quelles seraient les
éventuelles pistes de remédiation bah
notamment reconnaître le sol comme
milieu à partentière pour en faire une
idée de de politique politique nationale
non pas tant comme le sol patrimoine
commun de la nation puisque vous avez
déjà délibéré sur la question elle est
passée en sous en sous-ordre mais ça
serait surtout le la la capacité de
service du sol les services rendus par
le sol qui feraient partie du patrimoine
commun de la nation il y aurait
également parce que ça permettrait
également de de de de mettre en évidence
l'intérêt que l'on y porte il faudrait
également favoriser le recyclage foncier
avec tous les avantages qui sont
attachés expérimenter des dispositifs
d'économie des sols puisque vous savez
que désormais il est possible de faire
des des lois d'expérimentation sur
certains secteurs notamment à l'échelon
à l'échelon régional utiliser
éventuellement certains modèles
notamment le modèle suisse avec les
surfaces d'assolement qui permettent de
protéger de façon strictte sur
l'ensemble du territoire ce qu'on
appelle les meilleures terres agricoles
et qui sont totalement non
artificialisables et si elles l'était il
y aurait des compensation stricte de ce
point de vue-là euh vous avez également
aussi des un peu sur le modèle des
quotas de gaz eff effetè des quotas de
constructibilité il y a des
expérimentations qui se font en
Allemagne et qui permett donc de d'avoir
des idées d'économie puisque moins on
construit en surface plus on économise
en terme de droit et puis on pourrait
également promouvoir les services
écosystémiques des sol sol par leur
identification effective par un
rattachement particulier soit la
propriété soit comme patrimoine commun
soit par d'autres dispositif et puis les
évaluer et jouer avec comme l'a présenté
Lionel rangeard avec le projet prodige
auquel je participé également à Dijon
avec des indicateurs avec des référents
d'usage des référentiels qui permettrai
de dire que certains types de sol ne
peuvent être affectés qu'à tel et tel
usage et pas tel autre voilà merci
beaucoup merci je vais donner la par en
visio à François des cœur merci encore
d'être présent visio
merci votre micro est branché vous
m'entendez là
oui là c'est bon
ou bienécoutez je je vous remercie
d'avoir invité l'association des ma de
France à vos à vos travaux surtout
concernant ce sujet ce sujet
qui que que je découvre sans découvrir
mais que que je pense qu'il aurait fallu
qu'on qu'on le connaisse un peu plus
avant de de travailler le zan en fait
parce que c'est c'est vraiment le le la
présentation qu' a eu quand je suis
arrivé sur sur sur la nature du sol et
et la biodiversité qui peut y avec 59 %
de biodiversité dans dans le sol par
exemple fait que on ne peut pas échapper
à prendre toutes ces considération pour
travailler le zan en fait alors le zan
on n'est pas opposé nous au Zanin à
l'association des mes ruraux de France
on est opposé euh à la méthode et à la
méthode de qui est utilisée pour le
mettre en place et on est on on pense
que c'est pas très adapté au monde rural
en fait mais pour ce qui concerne la
nature du du sol c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui qui doit
maintenant faire l'objet alors il y a il
y a certaines collectivités qui ont la
chance d'avoir sans doute des élus ou
des ou des professionnels qui
connaissent bien le sujet et qui l'ont
pris en compte mais je pense pas que ça
soit la majorité dans dans le cadre
national et je pense qu'il serait très
important puisque c'est maintenant les
scottes qui vont probablement gérer la
mise en place des du zan il faut il faut
vraiment que ce volet là soit aborder de
manière très forte parce que c'est c'est
c'est l'avenir un peu de de
notre l'avenir de notre vie de la
qualité de la vie et de pas faire de
bêtises en ce qui
concerne la répartition des notamment
des nouvelles surfaces sur le territoire
les nouvelles surface à
urbaniser
alors c'est vrai que dans le monde rural
vous savez il y a un bon sens naturel
qui fait que souvent on voit bien que
les agriculteurs ouou ou les gens
connaissent bien leur terrain et et
connaissent bien sans sans le définir
scientifiquement connaissent bien la
nature du sol et d'ailleurs on le voit
très bien dans leur pratique ils
n'utilisent pas le sol n'importe comment
ilutilise en fonction effectivement leur
qualités agronomique ou autre ou
hydrologique notamment mais euh il
l'utilise par le bon sens souvent et par
une culture de de terrain en fait
euh il se trouve que il va falloir
maintenant que sur le plan de de de
l'urbanisation on on l'applique d'une
manière peut-être un peu différente pour
bien faire prendre conscience aux
habitants en général que le sol est est
capital est capital et je trouve que
c'est dommage que j'ai ce discours
aujourd'hui après avoir travaillé 3 ans
sur le sur le zan dans le cadre de la
MRF avec l'ensemble des ministère
concerné mais bon c'est comme ça donc il
faut faut qu'on on essaie de de
rattraper la situation on a la chance de
vous avoir parmi ceux que j'ai pu
écouter tout de suite et je crois que il
va falloir que bien qu'on on prenne
beaucoup plus en considération alors moi
je suis pas un sol comme vous c'est
trèsès très enthousiasment de vous
écouter mais par contre si vous voulez
me poser des question par rapport au an
dans le monde rural
notamment par rapport à la qualité du
sous-sol n'hésitez
pas merci et bien je vais donner la
parole à nos collègues et je vais don la
parole à Guillaume
chevrolier merci monsieur le Président
merci différents intervenants on voit
bien que la la santé des sols est un
sujet majeur moi je voudrais aborder le
le rôle des des sols dans le le grand
cycle de l'eau je pense notamment à la
capacité des sols une capacité
purificatrice et dépollutive lors de
l'infiltration des précipitation dans
les nappes mais également leur pouvoir
de de régulation des eau de surface à
même d'amoindrir les dégâts causés par
par les inondations et de réguler les
les crues qui sont malheureusement
d'actualité les agences de l'eau
promuvent depuis
plusieurs décennies les solutions
fondées sur la nature ce que nous
soutenons également avec la renaturation
et le reméandrage de certains cours
d'eau mais à ma connaissance
n'interviennent qu'assez peu sur les
sols aux abords des des cours d'eau
alors ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
rangeard précisément pour améliorer
l'absorption des des sols et leur rôle
d'éponge naturel quels sont les les
enseignements que vous tirez de vos
observations et de vos recherches et
quelles sont les bonnes pratiques en la
matière ou au contraire les erreurs à ne
pas à commettre et en quoi le diagnostic
précis et la cartographie précise des
sols permettrait-il de mettre en œuvre
un aménagement du territoire plus
respectueux des des sols ma seconde
question porte sur la la Stratégie de
Réduction du rythme de
l'artificialisation des sols donc ça a
été évoqué le le zéro artificialisation
nette donc j'insiste pas sur les
difficultés de sa mise en œuvre et les
complexités du dialogue territorial pour
répartir les baisses de consommation
foncière qui sont bien réelles et que
l'on retrouve dans dans l'ensemble des
régions de France mon interrogation
porte plutôt sur un volet encore négligé
et pourtant essentiel puisqu'il sert à
calculer le ratio du zan à savoir la
renaturation des sols vous avez parlé de
réhabilitation des sols monsieur le
professeur la loi climat et résilience
laa défin comme une action une opération
de restauration ou d'amélioration de la
fonctionnalité d'un sol j'aimerais
connaître l'efficacité des opérations de
désartificisation et les progrès en
matière de génie pédologique pour
améliorer la qualité des sols sans avoir
à prélever de la terre sur des sols
naturels ou agricoles à des coûts
économiques et environnementaux élevés
en effet dans le cadre normatif actuel
plus aucune artificisation ne pourra
être effectuée à partir de 2050 sans la
restauration d'une surface au moins
équivalente il est donc essentiel que
l'ingénierie et la connaissance du
fonctionnement des sols progressent
rapidement dans cette logique à qui
pourrait être confié la tâche de
s'assurer de l'efficacité de la de la
renaturation quel sont les principaux
points de vigilance que vous identifiez
en amont de l'élaboration des
certificats de renaturation dont la
valeur sera la même quel que soit le la
localisation le territoire national la
région Bretagne ou la Région Pays
d'Alois merci pour vos
réponses avant avant de répondre je vais
donner la parole à un autre intervenant
puis après vous répondrez et je donnerai
une deuxième série de je la parole à
Nicole
Bonnefoi merci merci monsieur le
Président Madame la vice-présidente
monsieur le professeur Monsieur le
Directeur mes chers collègues comme vous
le savez
peut-être j'ai déposé une proposition de
loi avec quelquesuns de mes collègues
pour la préservation des sols vivants
qui a pour objet de fixer un cadre à la
reconnaissance de la qualité des sols
dans notre droit commun et vous l'avez
évoqué au même titre que la qualité de
l'eau ou ou celle de l'air cette
évolution du droit et vous l'avez
rappelé recommandé de depuis des années
pour donner corps aux soins que nous
devons absolument porter aux vivants la
France dispose d'une réelle expertise en
matière de connaissance des sols et a
mis sur pied des outils efficaces
d'analyse le texte de loi que je propose
est d'établir un cadre rénové pour un
pilotage de la ressource en vue d'une
transformation des usages afin de
garantir les services écosystémiques et
ils sont nombreux rendus gratuitement
par les sols pour en citer quelquesuns
et vous l'avez déjà dit et c'était bien
mentionné dans le diaporama captage de
carbone conservation de la biodiversité
régulation du climat contrôle des
maladies et des ravageurs filtration de
l'eau et cetera grâce au diagnostic les
usagers de la Terre pourraient se saisir
de méthodes simples et vérifiées pour
améliorer la fertilité des sols le
programme
écovitisol réalisé par notre intervenant
Lionel rangard démontre bien la capacité
que nous avons aujourd'hui de
transformer les pratiques agricoles et
viticoles et de réconcilier les usages
avec la protection des sols donc je
remercie chaleureusement notre
commission d'avoir organisé cette table
ronde dédiée à la santé des sols qui
vient opportunément enrichir nos
réflexions à quelques semaines de l'exam
de l'examen de une proposition de loi et
dans le cadre plus global du futur
projet de loi d'avenir agricole mais
aussi et vous l'avez rappelé du projet
de directive européenne donc ce texte
peut constituer un premier pas important
pour la préservation des sols
euh quelques questions maintenant pour
monsieur
rangejard pourriez-vous préciser
l'importance du sol dans la filtration
de
l'eau une bonne gestion des sols
peut-elle avoir un impact sur les
problématiques que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui par exemple sur le
gonflement des sols argileux euh quel
moyen d'intervention en milieu
urbain les outils de diagnosticque vous
permettent-ils d'analyser l'ensemble des
sols et de préconiser des actions
précises sur tout type de sol que ce
soit des prairies des forêts des vignes
ou des grandes
cultures vous relevez que dans les
vignes et les grandes cultures on perd
80 % des réseaux d'interaction de la
microbiologie des sols les réseaux sont
moins cohésifs et donc le fonctionnement
du sol va être impacté la vitalité de
ces réseaux d'interaction est-elle la
condition d'une bonne fertilité des sols
sur l'étude écovitisol que vous avez
mené auprès des viticulteurs borignon
quelle a été la réception de votre
démarche les pratiques recommandé
ont-elles été appliqué par les
viticulteurs et évalué à
postériori ainsi avez-vous pu constater
notamment une diminution des pesticides
grâce à l'application de ces bonnes
pratiques et et pensez-vous que cette
méthode peut être élargie à l'ensemble
du territoire et des euh d'autres types
de cultur et quel lapse de temps est-il
nécessaire pour retrouver une qualité du
sol appréciable voilà toutes mes
questions
et concernant concernant monsieur billet
je crois que nous partageons le même
souhait de voir le sol reconnu enfin
dans la loi française et j'espère qu'on
va y arriver et que le Sénat va y
contribuer et donc même si vous avez
déjà répondu en partie donc je voulais
vous interroger sur le zan quel regard
vous portez sur les évolutions récente
de la législation en particulier sur le
zan est-ce que vous pensez que le
législateur est allé assez loin dans la
lutte contre l'artificialisation même si
vous avez déjà en partie répondu en
émettant quelques recommandations
propositions voilà merci beaucoup merci
Monsieur Ranjard puis
monsieur 3 minutes50 bon je vais essayer
de de me remémorer toutes les questions
et de répondre de façon synthétique tout
d'abord les sols et le cycle de l'eau
puisque ça correspond à des questions
communes le sol est une matrice
fondamentale pour le le cycle de l'eau
euh alors tout d'abord en terme de de
rémédiation c'est un filtre le sol on le
connaît historiquement on compte
beaucoup dessus notamment pour certaines
molécules pesticides qui doivent se
biodégrader au niveau du sol avec des
résultats plus ou moins efficaces parce
que c'est toujours mesuré en laboratoire
et sur le terrain ça se passe toujours
un peu différemment la vie est un peu
compliquée et très dynamique euh la
structure du sol est très importante
pour alors pardon je reviens sur la la
biorémédiation les les organismes alors
on a des processus physiques on a des
processus chimiques de dégradation et
bien sûr on a des processus biologiques
et ce sont les plus importants qui sont
portés par la biodiversité et notamment
les bactéries et les champignons qui
sont des acteurs fondamentaux dans la
bioréédiation de toutes les molécules
que l'on est capable de mettre même des
molécules à une époque de la chimie le
paradoxe c'est que j'ai fait de la
chimie au début de mon parcours donc je
sais de quoi je parle où on faisait des
molécules qui n'existaient pas dans la
nature parce que justement on voulait
qu'elle reste longtemps et qu'elle soit
efficace longtemps DDT lindane et cetera
et et donc même les microorganismes ont
mis certain temps mais ont trouvait des
voies de dégradation parce que c'était
une source de carbone et d'énergie donc
elles ont des objectifs d'utilisation de
la matière d'utilisation de l'énergie et
aussi de détoxification de leur
environnement donc on a des processus
biologiques qui sont très importants
mais ils sont pas toujours efficaces à
100 % donc le sol est un énorme filtre
en terme de biorémédiation en terme de
régulation des flux d'eau aussi la
porosité du sol est très importante et
maintenir la porosité d'un sol et
s'assurer que le sol est perméable et
que les flux d'au seront bien régulés
alors bien sûr quand il est
imperméabilisé le problème est différent
mais dans les sols agricoles il faut
éviter tout ce qui est assement et donc
c'est la biologie encore une fois et ce
sont encore une fois les bactéries et
les champignons qui créent la structure
du sol tout simplement parce qu'elles
créent leurs habitats elles créent des
agrégats dans lesquels elles vont
habiter ces agrégats font la porosité et
donc faut le côté perméable du sol et le
côté réserve hydrique aussi pour les
plantes et échange gazeux échange de
nutriments donc j'ai envie de dire la
biodiversité mais je suis écologue donc
je veux pas vous dire autre chose mais
mais c'est une vérité la biodiversité
est à l'origine de de ces différents
services et donc les solutions fondées
sur la nature sont importantes et donc
aux abords des rivières des aménagements
et dans dans les systèmes agricoles il
faut préserver cette qualité biologique
des sols qui entraîne une qualité
physique de structure du sol et aussi de
capacité de de dégradation quelles sont
les pratiques éviter les agressions
mécaniques éviter les agressions
chimiques comme on le connaît et couvrir
les sols une des pratiques les plus
agroécologique c'est la couverture des
sols on en reparlera sur le programme
écovitis sol c'est un gros problème en
vigne dans certains territoires pas tous
mais on a surtout une mauvaise
couverture en terme de durée et en terme
de diversité végétale au niveau des sols
agricoles et c'est ce qui pose problème
même dans les sols urbains d'ailleurs on
pourra en discuter sur le jardin du
Luxembourg pas parce qu'une pelouse est
belle qu'elle est diversifiée et
fonctionnelle et qu'elle stimule la vie
du sous on dit toujours en écologie que
si on a de la biodiversité audessus du
sol on aura de la biodiversité en
dessous du sol et inversement aussi
c'est-à-dire que s'il n'y a plus de
biodiversité dans le sol la biodiversité
végétale aura du mal à s'exprimer et à
se développer pour revenir sur
écovitisol qui est alors je savais pas
qu'on avait parlé d'covitisol
aujourd'hui j'en suis ravi parce que
c'est un peu peti projet qui me tient
beaucoup à cœur c'est un projet
participatif donc il y avait une
question de monsieur deskerur qui disait
travailler avec les agriculteurs il faut
sensibiliser le monde agricole on
travaille en projet participatif
directement avec les agriculteurs on l'a
fait en grande culture là on s'est
focalisé un peu sur la viticulture
pourquoi parce qu'on part un peu plus de
un peu d'un peu plus loin en viticulture
avec des pratiques historiquement un peu
plus agressives mauvaise couverture
beaucoup de mécanisation beaucoup de
pesticides et et donc on avait à cœur
aussi d'aller regarder la qualité des
sols je tiens à préciser avant de parler
des covid sol c'est qu'on a les outils
aujourd'hui on a des outils de
diagnostic qui proviennent de la
recherche pas tous ci ce de la recherche
s'il vous plaît ils sont objectifs
rigoureux et ils ont des référentiels
d'interprétation comme vous avez pu le
voir avec le rmqs et avec des projets
territoriaux le rmqs est assez grossier
mais il a le mérite d'exister il donne
déjà des tendances nationales et les
projets territoriaux comme le projet
prodige à Dijon sont des initiatives
très importantes pour affiner les
référentiels et les
diagnostics on perd 90 % des réseaux en
système viticol et on voit une
augmentation de la biodiversité c'est un
peu un chez les micro-organismes c'est
un peu un paradoxe microbien c'est que
les micro-organismes peuvent avoir des
augmentations de diversité du à des
perturbations et c'est une diversité
opportuniste qui n'amène pas
obligatoirement une bonne fonction et
une bonne fonctionnalité du sol et donc
ne remplit pas obligatoirement les écos
les services écosystémiques mais on a
toutefois la capacité de mesurer en fait
ces indicateurs et au niveau des vignes
donc dans ecovitisol on on est en train
de sensibiliser le monde viticol alors
ils sont déjà très très sensibiliser les
agriculteurs et les viticulteurs à la
qualité de leur sol ils l'entendent à
droite à gauche mais ils savent pas trop
quoi faire et donc dans ecovitisol on
fait différents territoires viticoles où
on compare les itinéraires techniques on
se compare on compare même les modes de
production bio conventionnel biodynamie
sur leur impact sur la qualité des sols
et notamment la qualité microbiologique
on voit des choses très intéressantes et
on part du principe que en fait
l'interprétation d'un diagnostic et la
comparaison des viticulteurs entre eux
permettra de les sensibiliser encore
plus et de leur faire adopter des
pratiques de leurs voisins c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne fait absolument pas de conseils
dans les covitisol on les fait se
comparer les uns par rapport aux autres
sur la base d'un diagnostic et ça marche
relativement bien puisque ceux qui sont
un peu meilleur que les autres sans
jugement de valeur et ben vont diffuser
très facilement à ceux qui sont un peu
moins bons par rapport à leur diagnostic
et par rapport à leur pratique que sont
les bonnes pratiques en viticulture
limiter le travail du sol enherber les
vignes de façon alors l'enherbement est
une vraie science et vraiment à
développer parce que il y a plein de
choses qui sont tâonnées des choses qui
marchent des ches qui qui marchent pas
réduire bien sûr les pesticides he qui
sont qui sont sont des biocides et on a
des territoires qui sont très vertueux
je vais citer l'Alsace he qui est un
territoire qui enherbe historiquement
puis des territoires un peu moins
vertueux en terme notamment
d'enherbement comme la Bourgogne je le
dis en étant au milieu des vignes en
Bourgogne donc mes voisins sont
viticulteurs et acceptent ce discours et
on les a même diagnostiqué donc c'est
très important ces projets parce que ça
permet de diffuser les bons indicateurs
et de comparer et de capter l'innovation
aussi chez les agriculteurs et les
viticulteurs parce que l'innovation
personnellement je suis persuadé quelle
est l'innovation des itinéraires
techniques chez les agriculteurs et les
viticulteurs et qu'il suffit de
l'évaluer et de la rediffuser à
l'échelle d'un territoire par contre ce
qui marche en Alsace n'est pas
obligatoirement applicable en Côte de
Provence ou dans lesraau ou en Bordelet
et le but des covitisol c'est de faire
tous les territoires viticoles en une
quinzaine d'années et et on est
cofinancé par les territoires eux-mêmes
donc il y a une véritable volonté locale
de connaître mieux la qualité de ces
sols et d'améliorer ces itinéraires
techniques en tout cas de savoir si ceux
qui sont développés vont dans le bon
sens je sais pas si j'ai répondu à
toutes les question
question sur question j'en a peux parlé
au début quand même qui pourrait
compensation qui pourra mesurer suivre
la réhabilitation des sol ah suivre la
réhabilitation des sols et ben ce sont
des des des des diagnostiqus des
indicateurs des tableaux de bord que
l'on est capable de faire et qui sont
transférés il y a des laboratoires
aujourd'hui privés qui ont acquéri
acquis les les indicateurs de de l'INRA
et qui sont capables de diagnostiquer la
qualité notamment la qualité biologique
des sols et certaines fonctions pour
faire des des des suivis des suivis de
de qualité des sols la réhabilitation ou
la question sur la réhabilitation des
systèmes agricole elle peut être assez
rapide pour les micro-organismes c'est
que les bactéries les champignons sont
des organismes à temps de génération
assez court on peut très vite les les
dégrader on peut très vite les les
altérer on peut aussi assez rapidement
les les réhabiliter c'est une question
classique des viticulteurs surtout ceux
qui ont un diagnostic rouge ou orange
ils nous disent en combien de temps
alors plus on part de loin plus c'est
long mais plus on applique les bonnes
pratiques plus ça sera rapide et
efficace et c'est peut être quelques
années ça sera pas deux ou trois
générations humaines ça peut être
quelques années pour réhabiliter la
qualité microbiologique d'un sol
agricole qui a été dégradé par des
mauvaises pratiques alors bien sûr tout
dépend de l'investissement dans ces
nouvelles pratiques et de l'État dont on
parle alors j'ai pas de réponse précise
à cette question je sais sur les
gonflements des des sols argileux mais à
partir du moment où les microorganismes
sont impliqués dans la structuration des
systèmes ils sont impliqués dans la
stabilité du système donc si un seul
argileux est est totalement dstructuré
parce que il y a des pratiques
agressives et que la microbiologie est
mauvaise euh si la microbiologie est
meilleur il va structurer il va euh
agréger les argiles et ça peut avoir un
effet de stabilisation par rapport à ça
mais j'ai pas de réponse précise sur
cette question je suis
désolé bien bien devant votre
micro c'est mieux comme ça merci oui
merci pour vos questions puis merci
votre pour votre proposition de loi que
j'ai j'ai j'ai lu et relu et on pourra
en rediscuter alors quelques quelques
éléments de ce que je pense du zan c'est
c'est un point de vue de juriste tout à
fait personnel mais en même temps assez
assez critique d'abord il a le mérite
d'exister mais je dirais pas qu'il vient
un peu tard ou il vient un peu trop en
trop puisque je crois me souvenir que le
slogan de la loi s rue du 13 décembre
2000 était reconstruire la ville sur la
ville et déjà on était dans des
resserrement des densifications et on
peut quand même s'interroger pourquoi il
a faillu la loi allure en 2014 pourquoi
il a fallu la loi en 2018 et maintenant
en 2021 le zanne si on n pas réussi déjà
depuis 25 ans à obtenir les résultats
que l'on souhaitait avec un certain
nombre de un certain nombre d'éléments
parce que je pense que avant de se poser
la question du comment on évite
l'artificialisation il aurait peut-être
fallu se poser la question du pourquoi
on artificialise pourquoi on
artificialise euh tout simplement parce
que comme vous le savez il y a des
millions de mètres carrés vacants donc
déjà du construit pour lesquels on on
manque quand même singulièrement de
texte pour avoir une occupation
effective alors certes il y a le sa
droit de propriété mais il y a également
de l'autre côté l'intérêt général
lorsque l'État veut s'investir dans ce
cadre là il sait le faire il y a la
question également de la désertification
là je rejoins monsieur le Président de
la MF en matière agricole il y a quand
même aussi le problème de la
désertification agricole enfin
désertification dans les campagnes et
qui fait qu'on va avoir besoin de plus
de construction en ville pour accueillir
les pour accueillir les les les
personnes mais dans le même temps on
laisse on laisse ses éléments ces
éléments vacants et peut-être qu'une
réflexion un peu plus poussée avant
d'aller sur le le zan aurait été ou en
même temps aurait été aurait été
intéressante ensuite ma deuxème
réflexion c'est je suis très surpris
qu'on critique autant un texte que le
zan avant même qu'il était mis en œuvre
puisque sa mise en œuvre est quand même
pour un certain temps et et je note
qu'il est de 2021 nous avons une loi du
20 juillet 2023 2 ans après alors même
qu'on l'a toujours pas mis en place
alors même si certaines communes
l'expérimentent mais sans sans ce
supportl puisqu'il n'est pas
d'application d'application immédiate a
une mission d'évaluation oui mais mais
c'est c'est quand même c'est quand même
assez assez surprenant et surtout c'est
que le dernier texte en date n'est pas
du comment améliorer le zan c'est
comment échapper au zan c'est quand même
curieux je trouve comme texte mais bon
ça ce sont mes mes réflexions de de de
juriste s'agissant s'agissant du du zan
en tant que tel je pense que on pourrait
améliorer peut-être en tout cas dans sa
fonction alité pour la question de la
réhabilitation des sols c'est
s'intéresser aussi à quelle pérénité
donner au sol réhabilité puis une fois
qu'il a été
réhabilité bah que devient-il est-ce
qu'il a la possibilité d'être plus tard
réartificialisé moyenant une heure une
désartificialisation ailleurs et cetera
on pourrait s'inspirer me semble-t-il de
la loi 2016 sur la biodiversité à propos
de la compensation écologique où on
prévoit notamment de des sorts des des
terrains qui ont fait l'objet de cette
réhabilitation en vue d'être affecté à
de la compensation la compensation
écologique premier point donc il me
semble qu'il faudrait peut-être apporter
une garantie supérieure que celle qui
fait sur le texte qui garantirait le
nonusage ultérieur des textes
éventuellement dans le cas du règlement
national d'urbanisme sous forme de
disposition d'ordre public qui
s'imposerait au plan loal d'urbanisme et
autres autres documents document
d'urbanisme ensuite peut-être également
puisqu'on parle de zéro
artificialisation nette mais on est dans
l'artifice ialisation des artificiations
du point de vue quantitatif de se placer
de nouveau avec la loi biodiversité de
2016 pour jouer peut-être sur
l'additionnalité écologique et pas
simplement faire un net mais un net plus
éventuellement en terme de de
désartificialisation ou en tout cas de
remise en bon état de de fonctionnalité
de fonctionnalité des fonctionnalité des
sols et puis éventuellement voir comment
on pourrait le transposer en matière
rurale puisqu'on a tout un certain
nombre d'éléments notamment sur l'entrée
en bail sur la l'évaluation de l'état
des sols et la sortie de bail sur
l'évaluation de l'état des sols trouver
des référents qui sont un peu différents
désormais et qui seraiit plus en terme
de bonne santé des sols et pas
simplement en terme de capacité de
produire ce qui est quand même très
singulièrement différent même si un sol
peut bien produire parce qu'il est en
bonne santé mais aussi peut produire
parce qu'il est en mauvaise santé mais
ça on l'intégre pas il y aurait
peut-être un certain nombre de
d'amélioration ou de modification à
apporter voilà je m'en tiens là pour le
moment merci
merci professeur je j'étais en train de
regarder un document inspiration vous
allez je pense le recevoir qui est très
intéressant effectivement ça reprend
bien ce que vous dites parce que
Jean-Baptiste blanc le rapporteur
sur titre l'acceptabilité la clé pour
atteindre le zone effectivement c'est
vrai que c'est déjà une difficulté alors
que c'est pas mis en place et vous avez
raison souligner je vais donner la
parole à Gold
merci monsieur le Président merci aux
différents intervenants alors
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
collectivités qui sont en cours
d'élaboration de documents d'urbanisme
de collectivité ou de PCI d'ailleurs
avec des zonages à définir qui
engendreront automatiquement des
conséquen en matière de constructibilité
et en matière de
préservation alors François DESC disait
tout à l'heure parlait du bon sens en
milieu rural je sais pas si le bon sens
est suffisant parce qu' à mon avis un N
jeu de de de connaissance on on ne
protège bien que qu'on que ce qu'on
connaît bien finalement et moi j'aerais
savoir si d'après vous est-ce que
d'abord quels sont les outils dont
disposent les collectivités pour
construire des documents d'urbanisme les
les plus efficaces possi qui prennent en
compte à la fois les caractéristiques
des sols
euh avec celles qui sont essentielle
c'estàd qui ont une valeur patrimoniale
à protéger
euh moi j'ai j'ai j'ai l'impression que
vous parliez tout à l'heure des
diagnosties de l'INRA et cetera je suis
pas certain quand on fait les documents
d'urbanisme qu'on a forcément accès à
ces documents là ou en tous les cas que
ça rentre dans le
processus d'élaboration donc voilà moi
ma question c'est surtout c'est surtout
celle-ci est-ce qu'on a une des
véritables outils de connaissance
lorsqu'on construit les documents
d'urbaniste qui sont quand même de façon
en terme de planification ou en terme
opérationnel les documents qui qui
servent à préserver aussi au-delà de la
constructibilité des terrains merci la
parole est à Olivier
Jacquin merci président puis merci pour
cette table ronde absolument
passionnante avant de poser ma question
un conseil de lecture à mes collègues
pour les fêtes le roman de Gaspar ganzer
humus parle de la vie des sols euh oui
c'est ça
euh Gaspar ganzer parle de la vide
Gaspar kenic pardon merde
oui je me suis trompé
parle alors je vais essayer de terminer
merci parle de la vie des sols et
notamment décrit très finement la
question de l'éch anxiété chez les
jeunes générations et il est passionnant
de ce point de vue-là et en plus la
scène finale se déroule dans le jardin
du Luxembourg et au Sénat et ça vous
amusera à un certain niveau alors mes
trois questions précises à Monsieur
rangjard l'agronome de l'agriculteur que
je suis vous l'avez un peu évoqué mais
l'utilisation des phytosanitaires et je
pense particulièrement au
fongicides relativement au champignons
présents dans les sols est-il sont-ils
compatibles avec une bonne vie du sol la
deuxème question les tenants de
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
mett en avant la seule question du
carbone et de la dilution de la matière
organique dans le cadre des nombreux
services écosystémiques rendu par les
sols ils font abstraction des phyos et
de la qualité de l'eau peut-on réduire
ainsi la problématique de la vie des
sols une dernière question très
technique s'agissant de la dilution de
la matière organique par un travail du
sol trop profond avez-vous des données
favorables des nouvelles technologies de
travail superficiel comme les charrues
des chôummeuses apparu récemment et puis
une dernière question à qui le veut sur
le
zan peut-être à Monsieur deckur ou à
Madame Gerardo plutôt que d'esquiver ne
vaudrait-il pas mieux aider les petites
collectivités à
tant en en moyen financier qu'en
ingénierie car la densification coûte
plus cher que l'utilisation intensive
des sols je vous
remercie cette dernière question est est
à à l'encontre de l'Association des
mares ruraux de France c'est
notre invité qui répondra je vais donner
la parole on va je vais donner une série
de questions et puis après vous
répondrez globalement je don la parole à
Michael Weber
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
pour cette table ronde euh je voudrais
d'abord rebondir sur ce que disait
François descœur parce que je pense que
c'est important que euh quand on quand
on fait le le bilan et notamment sur le
la loisane effectivement n'a peut-être
pas suffisamment pris en compte ce qui
était les sols hein dans cette
explication de la loi et sur le constat
je rebondirais sur ce que disait Olivier
Jacquin tout à l'heure la question c'est
pas simplement de limiter
l'artificialisation des sols
l'utilisation des sols mais c'est aussi
c'est la densification et de
l'utilisation de du déjà là puisque je
rappelle qu'il y a quand même 3 millions
de logements vacants en France pour
lesquels on a peut-être pas de solution
mais ceci étant dit je trouve que
l'intérêt que l'on a aujourd'hui pour
les sols et sa biodiversité leur
biodiversité est plutôt un élément
d'actualité parce que ça fait pas
longtemps en infin qu'on s'intéresse à
cette biodiversité des sols c'est le cas
chez nous aujourd'hui on le voit autour
du débat autour de la proposition de loi
de Nicole Bonnefois c'est aussi le cas
au niveau européen et ça contribue il me
semble à cette clatique des biens
communs qui sont dont on parle l'air
l'eau sans doute et donc aujourd'hui
peut-être les soluls euh et donc ça
m'amène à quelques questions euh quand
on traite de la biodiversité vous avez
tout à l'heure cité la loi de 2016 on
parle de corridor écologique et on et on
a on essaie de montrer qu'il y a des
liens notamment pour la faune peut-être
moins pour la flore mais est-ce que
cette notion finalement de corridor et
s'applique aussi au sol est-ce qu'il y a
une interaction entre les sols malgré la
distance en quelque sorte c'est c'est
c'est c'est un petit peu où est-ce qu'on
peut considérer que euh le fait d'avoir
une approche qui soit en pastile et bien
euh s'applique aussi à la prise en
compte euh à la prise en compte des sols
euh le deuxième élément qui peut-être
plus un élémen euh scientifique c'est
euh à l'échelle nationale est-ce que la
la bio la diversité pardon microbienne
est-elle impactée par l'homogénéisation
des cultures en France notamment les
céréales occupent 60 % des terres
arables et donc quel est l'impact de ce
point de vue là et lespendage des Bou
que l'on que l'on applique beaucoup dans
les territoires représent-ell aussi un
risque pour la vie souterrainee et
l'équilibre du cycle naturel des
nutriments et puis on a parlé tout à
l'heure des des outils que l'on pourrait
mettre en œuvre alors je sais pas si ça
a été évoqué dans les différents là je
je m'adresse aux intervenants en quelque
sorte quel qu'il soit on a beaucoup
parlé des obligations réelle
environnementale est-ce que ça peut être
un outil utilisé parce que on en parle
peut-être plus sur la question de la
forêt moins sur l'utilisation ou sur la
la protection des sols est-ce que ces
obligations réelles environmentales qui
ont été mis en place en 2007 pourrai
être un outil à utiliser pour protéger
les sols
merci je je don la parole àou et puis
après je vous donnerai la parole pour
répondre parce que j'ai encore un
certain nombre d'intervenants jeanou
merci monsieur le Président alors c'est
vrai que c'est une question qui a pas
été poser ça surtout concernant les
crues que nous vivons à l'heure actuelle
et les inondations donc vous le savez il
y a la présence de bois et et d'embacle
naturels qui sont en rivière de plus en
plus nombreux durant les cru qui ont été
faits dans les départements mais aussi
moi de dans les départements que ça soit
le nord ou le sud de la France nous
avons aperçu qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'ouvrages qui étaient menacés par
rapport à des embacles qui étaient
vraiment très nombreux dans les rivières
et ma question est la suivante c'est
dans un contexte de fort risque
d'inondation comme vous comme si z-vous
comme nous le rapportent les élus de
montagne par exemple dont j'en suis un
que nous devrions permettre un
assouplissement de la gestion des
embarques pour mieux protéger la
population à court terme mais aussi les
sols dans nos rivières et si oui
considérez-vous que notre législation
adaptée à ce nouveau défi de la
prévention des inondations quel pourrait
être selon vous le point d'équilibre
entre la protection des sols bien sûr et
une gestion des embarques moins risqué
c'est-à-dire qu'on s'aperçoit qu'au
niveau des cours d'eau il y a une
restriction au niveau des cours d'eau
par rapport au sol et est-ce que ça
serait pas quelque chose qui serait à
voir au niveau de notre réflexion pour
voir un peu comment on pourrait changer
peut-être notre législation par rapport
à ce domaine de la protection des
sols je vous propose de répondre merci
allez euh alors sur la première je
laisserai Philippe billet transfert des
outils et des connaissances pour les
documents d'urbanisme parce que c'est
c'est ce qu'on essaie de mettre en place
justement à l'échelle du du territoire
dijunis dans dans le projet prodige
d'alimenter véritablement toutes les
politiques publiques avec des outils et
des con essence sur les sols du
territoire donc je vais revenir alors
petite préc je suis pas agronome je suis
écologue je suis
désolé non non mais j'aime bien faire la
distinction je je travaille dans un
institut où il y a beaucoup d'agronomes
et et on travaille très bien ensemble
mais mais je représente plus de
l'écologie ce qui fait que
agronomiquement je je ne suis pas très
calé aussi sur toutes les techniques
même si j'en connais de plus en plus sur
les pratiques en terme de fongicide ben
oui oui un fongicide c'est un
antifongique et donc quand on le met sur
la plante au départ notamment en vigne
on en utilise beaucoup 80 % des
pesticides sont des sont des fongicides
en vigne et ça tombe au sol et donc
c'est ce qui explique qu'on a une forte
dépression dans les sols viticoles en
terme de quantité de microorganismes et
notamment de champignons et aussi de
réseaux d'interaction de diversité les
champignons avec une double peine he qui
est le travail du sol puisque on met
moins
d'herbicid dans les vignes on met
presque plus d'herbicides chimiques par
contre on des herbes mécaniquement donc
tout ceci fait qu'on on affecte la
biologie du sol l'agriculture de
conservation tout le monde se revendique
de l'agroécologie l'agriculture de
conservation l'agriculture biologique
on a fait une étude internationale une
métaanalyse scientifique internationale
sur l'impact de ces différents modes de
production bien sûr en regard du
conventionnel sur toute la biologie du
sol pas que la microbiologie alors déjà
la première la première conclusion c'est
qu'on on manque d'études on en aimerait
en voir plus il y en a plus d'une
centaine on commence à avoir des
tendances ce que l'on voit c'est que
l'agriculture de conservation est
meilleure que l'agriculture
conventionnelle en terme de biologie du
sol le bio aussi est au même niveau mais
pour des raisons différentes
l'agriculture de conservation elle
limite le travail du du sol il y a même
plus de travail du sol il y a une forte
couverture des sols donc tout ça c'est
très bien pour la la biologie en général
par contre on continue d'utiliser des
engrais de synthèse et des pesticides dû
à des impaces techniques hein d'ailleurs
pas voilà pas par volonté absolue et le
bio de l'autre côté ben le le bio n'a
plus de pesticides de synthèse moins de
biocide plus de matière organique mais
pas toujours une bonne couverture et
souvent même on voit une augmentation du
travail du sol pour les conversion en
bio parce que et ben oui il faut gérer
les adventistes il faut gérer
l'interrang en her en Vig qui entraîne
souvent une baisse de rendement par des
notions de de compétition euh donc les
deux sont agroécologiques mais tout le
monde est au milieu du gay en fait les
deux sont mil du gay alors c'est vrai
que naïvement moi qui justement écologue
et pas agronome j'ai envie de me dire
faisons du bio en conservation ou de la
conservation en bio on me dit que c'est
impossible mais j'ai été contacté il y a
il y a 3 semaines par un groupe
d'agriculteurs en Mayenne qui fait ça
depuis 15 ans et qui nous demande de
venir travailler avec eux pour voir la
qualité de leur sol donc on va y aller
on va essayer de faire un groupe et on
va essayer d'appliquer nos outils de
recherche et de faire une production de
connaissance là-dessus parce que c'est
vrai que pour nous agroécologue c'est un
peu le système à à développer à ce
niveau-là et enfin la dilution de la
matière organique par rapport au type
d'engin de travail du sol n'étant pas
agronome alors souvent le paradoxe c'est
que souvent les agriculteurs sont dans
une réduction de travail du sol et
disent ah mais je gratte juste en
surface et cetera oui mais c'est en
surface où il y a l'essentiel de la
biodiversité notamment bactéries et
champignon c'est dans les 10 15 20
premiers centimètres donc bien sûr que
le labour
profond est de moins en moins utilisé et
cetera et qu'on on fait des systèmes de
griffage et mais ça continue quand même
d'agresser au moins en surface et c'est
là aussi où il y a le
carbone donc ça joue aussi sur sur le
cycle du carbone voilà
euh tu poursuis Philippe oui voilà bien
merci je vais répondre à la à la toute
première question donc s'agissant des
des indicateurs et autres tel qu'on a pu
le tel qu'on peut actuellement le
développer dans le cadre du projet
prodige à Dijon avec le Lionel ranger et
moi participons je vais simplement
d'abord rappeler qu'il y a eu un GR
groupe de travail qui s'appelait Gol il
y a une dizaine d'années qui était
initié par l'ADEM et le ministère de de
l'écologie et qui avait notamment au
titre de ces de ces projets un projet
qui s'appelait ualol et qui était
justement destiné à rechercher donc il a
un rapport he qui existe sur cette
question et qui essa de de rechercher en
expérimentant grandeur réelle la
possibilité de de mettre en place des
indicateurs de qualité des sols lesquels
indicateurs allaient conditionner
l'usage du sol qui pouvait être fait
avec des indicateurs qui montraient
qu'il y avait une utilisation à des fins
d'artificialisation qui était cette
fois-ci proche de qui était de zéro
puisqu'on ne pouvait pas les les
artificialiser et d'autres qui auraient
été un peu plus commun et qui permettait
qui permettait C cet usage mais
visiblement comme beaucoup de rapports
il est un peu passé dans dans il est
resté dans les tiroirs s'agissant du
projet prodige qu'on a sur qu'on a sur
Dijon avec avec notamment le Grand Dijon
et et et la caissce des dépôts en fait
vous avez deux orientations de de de
travail tout d'abord de nouveau les
indices la question des indices de
qualité qui qui permettrait et donc
c'est d'établir un espèce de de cahier
des charges en tout cas d'abord une
première réflexion puis ensuite un
cahier des charges pour les
collectivités local pour justement les
éclairer sur quel usage pour quel sol et
non pas euh puisque le droit est quand
même assez magique hein on fait ce qu'on
veut avec le droit on dit si ce sol est
constructible il devient constructible
quel que soit sa qualité sauf les
questions de qualité mécanique mais ces
questions de qualité euh euh de fond ne
sont ne sont ne sont que très rarement
prises en compte et l'idée de prodige
c'est justement d'introduire ce critère
de de de qualité dans le dans l'usage
des sols et puis l'autre sur l'élément
de qualité c'est qu'on joue aussi sur la
labellisation et d'essayer de voir mais
cette fois-ci la labellisation
alimentaire puisque c'est le le le
sous-intitulé de de de de prodige sur
l'alimentation alimentation 2030 c'est
la question de l'introduction de la
qualité des sols dans les labels puisque
si vous regardez la la tous les cahés
des charges des AOC IGP et cetera et
cetera vous n'avez pas la qualité du sol
en tant que tel et l'idée serait double
ici c'est d'introduire la la
labellisation sur la qualité de
l'aliment en tant que tel et la ensuite
la qualité de la façon dont on a
cultiver l'aliment sans remettre en
cause la qualité du sol ce fait que
cette labellisation serait double et
permettrait donc d'attester qu'il y a un
réel une réelle prise en compte or comme
vous le savez les questions de qualité
des sols sont essentielles en matière
d'urbanisme puisque dès lors qu'ils font
l'objet d'un label de protection on doit
passer par l'INAO pour avoir un avis
avant
l'artificialisation c'est à toiain
je veux bien répondre sur comment on
fait pour soutenir les territoire sur
leur par rapport à leur densification
alors je vais parler avec le prisme des
compétences départementales puisque
c'est de cette manière que que qu'on
peut agir euh par exemple dans nos
financements au territoire c'est vrai
que la la le dispositif cœurde Bour est
est central et et si on a des projets
qui nous sont soumis et qui ne sont pas
dans l'enveloppe qui a été défini dans
le plan guide ils vont pas être
éligibles au financement donc c'est déjà
une manière d'orienter euh aussi
travailler étroitement avec les
collectivités dans notre cadre de
politique de soutien au territoire pour
les orienter vers les les bons outils
pour les conseiller quand une
collectivité parle d'un projet
d'extension urbaine pour du logement et
qu'elle n'a pas fait d'études pour
pouvoir se projeter dans l'avenir avoir
de la prospective sur ses capacités par
rapport à la dynamique démographique à
ses possibilités
d'intervention foncière et cetera bien
forcément elle n'est pas armée elle va
subir plutôt que qu'agir renforcer aussi
les moyens de l'établissement public
foncier ça c'est essentiel et je je
crois que voilà il y a des il y a des
marges de progrès à faire sur ça une
démarche de de dialogue avec je parlais
des événements et cetera pour faire
comprendre et aussi et et aussi quand on
quand on discute des financement que si
il y a des extensions de SuperU ou des
des nouveaux commerces
éloignés qui vont favoriser l'extension
urbaine on va pas pouvoir mobiliser les
financements départementaux parce qu'on
peut pas donner de l'argent public et
qui a pas de cohérence dans la politique
qui va vider les les commerces du
centrebourg et cetera donc tout ça c'est
c'est aussi de l'animation c'est des
c'est des outils promouvoir aussi le
dialogue dans les intercommunalités
essayer de d'avoir des une politique où
on peut on prne bah la mutualisation de
certains équipements voilà qui vont qui
vont pouvoir permettre bah de de de de
de conforter cette nécessaire
densification et et centralisation euh
dans les collèges du département on
construit aujourd'hui des collèges où on
pense les collèges existants dans la
capacité à avoir des usages voilà
multiples les association le weekend et
cetera donc c'est tout un tas de petites
choses je pense que c'est c'est un état
d'espritfin on a dit plusieurs fois
pourquoi on le fait en fait si on a bien
compris pourquoi on le fait en fait les
idées elles viennent aussi un petit peu
plus spontanément alors c'est pas
magique mais et puis euh on a de la
chance je crois voilà les agences
d'urbanisme et on a quand même plein
d'outils plein d'acteurs qui peuvent
accompagner même si je l'évoquais sur
les enjeux de fiscalité la question des
financements elle est essentielle sur
les or euh on commence tout juste à à à
à mettre en place enfin à tester euh
dans en Pays de la Loire il y c'est le
Conservatoire des espaces naturels qui
porte surtout cette cette politique là
et cette expertise euh on essaie de d'y
réfléchir notamment pour les délaissés
fonciers euh quand on a des tracés
routiers et cetera que quand on revend
du foncier départemental ce soit
accompagné d'ore pour garantir que bah
certains espace qui qui ont été
propriété du département voilà il y a
une une une sécurisation en fait de la
qualité du sol et des enjeux
biodiversité
notamment mais c'est le tout début je je
peux poursuivre donc sur les ux
éventuellement parce que vous me tendez
la la perche oui effectivement sur le
plan juridique rien ne s'oppose
absolument à la mise en place d'ux pour
la protection et effectif du sol puisque
le texte est assez générique dans sa
dans sa rédaction puisqu'il vise le
maintien la conservation la gestion ou
la restauration d'élément de
biodiversité ou de fonction écologique
sans se préoccuper de la nature du
milieu hein qui est qui est visé or
comme vous le savez naturellement on
peut protéger le sol également que si on
protège la surface parce que c'est
l'élément essentiel au regard des
travaux et on le voit bien notamment
puisque le texte donne la seule limite
d'ailleurs dans sa mise en œuvre et la
seule opposition qu'on pourrait avoir
d'ailleurs c'est que si le le terrain
fait l'objet un bail rural il ne peut
être mis en eireux que si vous avez
l'accord du preneur à bail donc ça ça
limite mais ça montre bien qu'on est
bien dans un problème de bouleversement
de la surface qui pourrait porter
atteinte au au sol et à sa biodiversité
en tant que telle pour revenir sur la la
question qui a été posée sur la la
biodiversité des sols et notamment ce
qu'on appelle dans notre jargon la trame
brune parce que vous avez la trame verte
et bleue on a inventé la trame noire
dans la lo biodiversité puis on
s'oriente désormais même si ça reste un
peu une chimère sans doute mais el
rangard nous en parlera un peu plus la
trame brune c'est-à-dire le fait qu'on
ait des corridors de déplacement
écologique en sous-sol donc ce qui qui
nécessite d'avoir une certaine qualité
du sol pour permettant la la circulation
des des éléments des éléments qui s'y
trouvent je me demande si on ne pourrait
pas aller dans le même sens que la
dertifk 2060 sur l'eau avec ces trois
critères et qu'on a qu'on a jamais
véritablement appliqué au au au sol
c'est des critères de bon état
biologique de bon état chimique et de
bon état physique
on a un certain nombre d'éléments d'
directive C dans mon labo on a conduit
une étude y a quelques temps sur
justement est-ce qu'il serait possible
de transposer les données de la sur
l'eau au sol puisqu'on a déjà une
expérimentation et une application en
tant que telle et et en fait on s'est
rendu compte que rien ne s'y opposait
effectivement alors nonobstant les
nécessaires adaptations puis qu'on est
pas tout à fait dans le même dans le
même milieu mais on a quand même déjà un
certain nombre de de référents de
critères qui pourrait être qui pourrait
être valorisé dans ce cadreel
je veux bien rebondir là-dessus parce
que j'avais aussi mis mis cette idée
dans mon intervention mais aussi à la
fois parce qu'il y a une vraie logique
je pense qu'il y a un parallèle et puis
en plus il y a une logique dans dans les
critères et il y a une logique parce
qu'on peut pas dissocier l'eau et le sol
il y a aussi un intérêt par rapport aux
enjeux climatiques parce que le un sol
sec les enjeux d'inondation et cetera en
fait si on veut renforcer l'adaptation
je pense que une approche type
dceo qui est couplée avec une approche
type DCE sol ça R force aussi des
stratégies d'adaptation futur donc ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
très intéressant à à creuser et je
voulais compléter mon intervention
précédente avec un outil qui est qui est
utilisé aussi dans le département et
dans quelques que départements c'est
l'outil payant alors certains
l'appellent différemment c'est les
périmètres de protection des espaces
naturels et et agricoles donc à la base
donc on a trois payants en Loir
Atlantique sur à peu près 26000 hectares
donc c'est un outil qui permet de
sanctuariser un un
périmètre d'espace naturel et agricole
qui ne pourront plus être artificialisés
il faut l'accord des communes de
l'interco et du département et une fois
que ce périmètre est est établi avec un
programme d'action associé il est il est
protégé contre enfin de
l'artificialisation mais ce qui est
intéressant à ce titre là donc
évidemment c'est un outil qui permet
facilite notamment la la mise en œuvre
de la
loan mais c'est que le programme
d'action et les moyens qui sont associés
permettent de travailler
sur de l'animation notamment agricole
donc la Chambre d'Agriculture est partie
prenante des C de cespen et dans la
gouvernance il y a un comité de pilotage
avec d'autres parties prenante mais je
vais pas détailler avec notamment bah du
coup des conversations sur des enjeux
comme l'installation transmission des
exploitations quand on sait que il y a
la moitié des exploitants qui vont
partir dans des prochaines années donc
c'est essentiel mais aussi sur les
enjeux de tram vert et bleu
d'articulation avec les contrats
territoriaux territoriaux haut et cetera
et donc on a un peu d'une pierre trois
coupsou d'une pierre quatre coup enfin
je sais pas combien on peut dire mais
entre à la fois une logique de
protection de l'artificialisation des
sols mais la capacité à travailler le
projet agricole dans la préservation des
de ces sols sur les pratiques les modes
d'exploitation qui sont présentes sur
sur ce sur ce paiant donc voilà juste
pour dire qu'au niveau départemental cet
outil est aussi intéressant et que on
vient de finir la la le bilan puisque
les premiers paiants dans le département
donc on en a trois on en a deux nouveaux
qui nous sont demandés par les
différentes communes le bilan est
positif dans tous les payants c'estàdire
que tous les élus des communes
concernées souhaite le muscler le
renforcer et le voit comme une boîte à
outils pour pour aller plus loin donc
c'est intéressant voilà de de de de de
de regarder un petit peu cet outil parce
qu'il permet pas mal de
choses monsieur dekerer vous le
souhaitez intervenir ou
pas votre
micro
si le micro est
ouvert c'est bon je on vous entend bon
oui sol o
r vous rapprocher de votre micro c'est
très très bien c'est très très bien que
vous essayez de de voindre un petit peu
le sol à ces deux éléments qui sont des
éléments vitaux en fait bon er gold
disait tout à l'heure que peut-être
qu'au niveau des documents c'était
c'était difficilement accessible pour
certaines communes l'exemple de Dijon
est formidable mais vous savez quand on
est dans le monde rural on n pas
beaucoup de documents qui nous
permettent de de juger de de la qualité
de du sol par exemple alors c'est vrai
que moi je vous vous parlais tout
simplement de l'effet mémoire et de
l'effet et de l'effet des gens qui
vivent sur le terrain et qui ont une
certaine connaissance évidemment ça n'a
rien de scientifique mais euh ça
pourrait être beaucoup plusamélioré avec
et ça je pense que ça viendra parce que
le le sol estant primordial il faut que
ça il faut qu'on en arrive à avoir des
données beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
intéressante effectivement qui nous
permettent de beaucoup plus juger des
choses alors après euh moi je pense que
il est il faut il est il est hors de
question de dire qu'on ne peut pas
améliorer le zan parce que le zan
n'existe pas c'est pas c'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout un argument c'est le
zan existe dans le texte et euh il faut
que vous vous rapprochiez un peu plus du
monde rural de du vrai monde rural saz
moi j'ai une communauté de communes 27
communes 18 communes sur les 27 qui sont
en RNU et le reste qui ont un document
d'urbanisme dans la plus petite commune
à 40 habitants euh est-ce que vous
trouvez très raisonnable que on oblige
toutes ces communes à faire un document
d'urbanisme pour pour intégrer le zan et
notamment les les 1 hectare qui sont
attribués à soi-disant à ce à cet effet
alors je pense
que c'est c'est là où où il faut faut
faire très attention c'est qu'il y a
quand même une grosse différence je
pense entre le monde rural et le monde
urbain et que le zan n'est pas je veux
pas opposer le monde urbain et rural
loin de là moi je je suis vice-président
d'un EPF au vernia clermonttoit euh et
le monde urbain je connais parfaitement
bien mais je suis m d'un village rural
très rural et je je pense que là on a
oublié quelque part on a un petit peu
oublié quelque part que le monde rural
avait des besoins différent voilà en
fait et ça je voulais quand même le
spécifier et je pense qu'on n pas parti
dans ce sens alors l'outil de le PF al
que Madame citait tout à l'heure est un
outil absolument formidable
effectivement qui pe qui peut apporter
beaucoup de choses et je pense que la
nature du sol doit doit maintenant
pouvoir être intégré
à à ces outils tels que EPF qui qui en
plus ont font l'objet d'une ouverture
importante en terme de réflexion
aujourd'hui alors voilà ce que je
voulais dire euh il faut qu'il y ait une
certaines dans dans ces discours qui
sont absolument fabuleux il faut qu'on
ait quand même une certaine
considération
humaine humaine humaniste par rapport au
monde rural et je pense que je je lance
un appel à vous tous pour pour écouter
cette phrase en fait
voilà merci merci je vais poursuivre je
vais donner la parole à RV
gilet merci monsieur le Président j'ai
suivi avec beaucoup d'attention les les
différentes interventions et en
continuité bien sûr de l'intervention de
de Nicole concernant sa PPL vous
indiquez que nous avons eu une mission
d'information sur la gestion durable de
l'au un rapport a été rendu mi-juillet
et dans cette mission d'information bien
sûr elle soulligne toute l'importance
notamment d'entretien des zones humides
dans la gestion de l'eau aujourd'hui et
d'inscrire ces objectifs en termees
stratégiques d'une manière beaucoup plus
forte aujourd'hui dans les documents
d'urbanisme et il y a forcément et vous
l'avez souligné une liaison entre la
gestion de l'eau et puis donc la
biodiversité au niveau des au niveau des
sols donc ce que nous souhaiterions
faire c'est justement faire en sorte que
au niveau des Scott et des plui on aille
vers une gestion aussi stratégique de
l'eau qui permettrait de mieux
entretenir aussi les sols et notamment
de de mieux entretenir ou de maintenir
les zones humides donc dans une approche
beaucoup plus stratégique dans ce cas de
figure ça veudrait dire puisque vous
parlez de trame brune à un moment donné
dans les scottes effectivement trame
vertte trame bleue chez moi je suis en
Gironde on a même parlé de de trame
pourpre pour la la viticulture euh mais
effectivement inscrire ou renforcer
aujourd'hui dans les Scotts cette vision
aussi stratégique des sols et notamment
entre autres au travers de la gestion de
l'eau donc j'aimerais avoir peut-être
vos réactions par rapport à à ces
propositionsl qui sont des propositions
qui peuvent trouver on va dire une
inscription réglementaire relativement
facilement c'est pas hyper complexe
d'essayer d'aller un peu plus loin
aujourd'hui au niveau des plui et des
Scotts notamment sur ces approches
stratégiques et donc en terme de de de
de Bénéfic assez rapide on peut avoir
des des évolutions assez notables sur
ces orientationsl et elles sont assez
majeures pour le coup parce qu'elles
permettent au travers des politiques des
collectivités territoriales d'avoir une
déclinaison vraiment territoriale de ces
politiques et de créer des articulations
dans les territoire avec l'ensemble des
des parties prenantes euh deuxième point
que je voulais avoir aborder avec vous
la notion plus de de capital qui est lié
au niveau des sols et quand on parle de
droit et de propriété il y a la notion
aussi de capital derrière et derrière la
la notion de capital aujourd'hui se pose
aussi la question de comment valoriser
le capital carbone et et c'est aussi un
sujet qui est particulièrement important
et qui parfois nous échappe d'ailleurs
parce que les compensations carbon sont
parfois trop dépendantes du privé et pas
suffisamment régulé au niveau du public
et donc il y a aussi un vrai sujet
autour du capital que peuvent apporter
les sols aujourd'hui et peut-être aussi
de stratégies privé publi que nous
pourrions développer dans les
compensations carbon et dans les aménité
qu'on pourrait développer pour préserver
et améliorer aussi les sols et renforcer
ce capital commun euh que nous pourrions
donc essayer de mieux gérer d'une
manière partagée qu'en
pensez-vous je ou je vais peut-être
donner la parole pour finir à tous mes
collègues euh Monsieur Saïd Omar
[Musique]
Wally merci monsieur le Président moi
j'ai juste une petite question vous
connaissez tous la problématique de
Mayotte on n'a pas d'eau euh depuis pas
mal de temps et que nous nous il pleut
pas et donc l'eau c'est dans les
retenues cinaires eu et de plus en plus
l'eau n'est plus consommable on a trouvé
du plomb et cetera et cetera donc c'est
la course aujourd'hui au forage alors
quelles sont les conséquences euh demain
à à moyen terme à long terme sur notre
biodiversité est-ce qu'il y a pas de
danger euh quelles sont les
recommandations que vous pouvez faire
pour que je puisse au moins alerter les
autorités locales merci beaucoup merci
chers collègues je vais donne la parole
à Christina
Pluchet merci monsieur le Président euh
écoutez moi je je voulais réagir un
petit peu sur un domaine que je connais
bien qui est le le domaine
agricole parce que j'ai encore une fois
un peu le sentiment d'entendre un
discours assez à charge sur la
conservation des sols contre le monde
agricole mais moi je connais pas une
seule entreprise qui ne prenne pas soin
de son utilé de
travail les agriculteur leur outil de
travail c'est le sol et c'est les
premiers effectivement à en prendre soin
chaque
année parce que c'est juste une évidence
à en faire à faire des prélèvements
effectivement pour pour faire faire
avoir des résultats technique de de de
de on va dire des de la qualité de leur
sol et je pense qu'effectivement de
depuis depuis un certain nombre d'années
ils font beaucoup d'effort si vous
voulez pour préserver cet outil de
travail et et et et je voulais rappeler
aussi que l'agriculture française est
l'agriculture la plus contrôlée la plus
normée et et je dirais même que la la
conditionnalité aux aid
pqu elle revient effectivement à une un
procédé extrêmement vertueux de
l'agriculture voilà donc voilà je pense
qu'il y a il y a eu une prise de
conscience il y a beaucoup d'eff for qui
ont été faits et ça c'est important de
le rappeler aujourd'hui et et je voulais
dire aussi que les les agriculteurs sont
sont garants aussi de notre souveraineté
alimentaire ça c'est très important euh
il est important de les comment on a
l'agriculture je dis la plus propre je
pense au monde il est important de le
rappeler et il est important de les
soutenir voilà et j'avais une petite
question aussi
sur l'agriculture de de conservation
comme vous la voyez aujourd'hui on sait
effectivement qu'elle est
hyperdépendante en
glyphosate et je voulais avoir votre
point de vue justement sur ce type
d'agriculture merci merci je donne la
parole à Fabien
Jeunet merci monsieur le Président
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été dites
donc voilà peut-être très bref
simplement par rapport à ce qui a été
dit puisque la Bourgogne a été mise en
cause en disant qu'elle était en retard
sur l'enerbement peut-être faudrait-il
nuancer un peu le propos Monsieur le
Directeur en disant que peut-être
certains territoires de Bourgogne sont
en retard lorsque vous venez du charolet
Brionnais comme moi naturellement vous
avez une analyse un peu différente et
j'espère que vous nous aiderez à classer
d'ailleurs les paysages du charolet BRI
Brionnais à l'Unesco puisque dans cette
action de l'élevage bovin sur les
paysages ce qui est la candidature à
l'Unesco bien sûr les sols ont toutes
leur importance eu deux deux autres
remarques peut-être sur effectivement la
la planification et le travail que nous
menons actuellement sur beaucoup de
territoires avec nos plu et nos plans
locaux d'urbanisme intercommunaux euh je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec Eric sur
le le fait que lorsque nous
devons siéger dans ces commissions de
travail votter ces documents les les
connaissances en la matière sont
certainement assez limitées pour ceux
qui sont autour autour de la table et
qui doit en délibérer et je pense qu'il
y a un effort de pédagogie à faire et
donc cette table ronde monsieur le
Président il participe tout à fait une
proposition peut-être révolutionnaire
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas qu'il
faudrait changer le vocable et passer du
PLU plui par exemple au post au Plan
d'Occupation des Sols ce qui permettrait
de mettre en avant la dimension dont
nous parlons ce matin et puis pour
conclure sur le le
zan monsieur le professeur si si je puis
me permettre d'avoir un avis un peu
différent du vôtre nous avons le
sentiment que le zan est déjà appliqué
il est déjà appliqué dans le décompte de
la période en cours il est déjà appliqué
par l'État et l'administration qui dans
la préparation des documents
d'urbanisme a tout à fait intégré cette
dimension et sur votre interrogation il
est toujours bon que nous ayons un
dialogue entre ceux qui votent la loi
qui essaye de le faire du mieux possible
et ceux qui vont ensuite aller
l'expliquer à leurs
étudiants s'il y a eu une modification
cet été et un nouveau texte sur le zan
c'est parce que jusqu'à présent la loi
n'est encore pas faite par chat GPT mais
par des représentants élus des
représentants élus certes des
territoires mais également des êtres
humains qui vent de qui qui vivent
dessus et donc lorsque nous sentons
qu'il y a des difficultés
d'acceptabilité mais également des
enjeux qui n'ont pas été pris en compte
je crois que c'est tout l'honneur du
législateur que de pouvoir corriger la
copie et d'améliorer les choses et
Monsieur le Professeur je peux vous dire
que de ce que nous vivons actuellement
il y aura certainement peut-être
d'autres modifications législatives qui
viendront dans les semaines ou mois qui
viennent euh au-delà de cette précision
euh ça a été dit par le représentant de
l'Association des Maes ruraux de France
euh il y a il y a cette dimension du bon
sens et je crois qu'il faut pas opposer
ceux qui auraient les connaissances et
ceux qui auraient le le le bon sens nous
sommes tous effectivement à vouloir
travailler ensemble à cette préservation
de la biodiversité certains y ont été
plus sensibles plus rapidement que
d'autres un certain nombre de sénateurs
ont été placés par leur groupe et j'en
fais partie dans cette commission pour
que nous puissions assurer notre
transition vers une meilleure prise en
compte des enjeux environnementaux mais
quand même le bon sens ce qu'on entend
sur le territoire pense que ce serait
bien qu'on vous fasse réagir
là-dessus ce qui ne va pas de soi c'est
de considérer que concentrer la
population à un endroit densifier ça
permettrait d'améliorer l'environnement
et je crois que dans beaucoup de
réactions épidermique que nous avons en
particulier en ruralité venir dire à des
gens qui habitent et vous connaissez la
Bourgogne vous traversez la Nièvre comme
moi voire même certains territoires de
ceellloir dans l'Ouest lorsque vous
traversez ces territoires ruraux aller
expliquer au au Mair rural au maire de
la commune rurale aux habitants que si
effectivement on met une maison en plus
ici on va détruire la nature détruire
l'environnement altérer la biodiversité
et que en concentrant en mettant encore
plus d'habitants autour de Dijon
lorsqu'on prend la rocade on voit c'est
ces ces habitations supplémentaires là
ça va être le moyen de
préserver l'environnement et d'améliorer
la biodiversité effectivement
beaucoup d'entre nous sur ces territoire
se posent des questions donc on est très
heureux d'entendre votre réponse sur le
sujet merci chers collègues le le bon
sens veut que effectivement j'ai bien
noté le le retour au post c'est très
intéressant louis- Jean de
Nicola oui merci monsieur le Président
moi j'ai juste une une simple question
nous sommes en dans les communes en
train de travailler sur la transition
les zones d'accélération de la
transition énergétique et je vois que
sur mon territoire il y a C ét
maintenant été souhaité par les présenté
par les élus il y a il y a la
concertation avec le public il y a une
assez forte demande de de panneau
d'agrivoltaïsme et donc je voulais
savoir si c'était vous pouvez confirmer
que c'est favorable justement à la
biodiversité que ça ne gêne pas la
biodiversité ou que c'est plutôt
inquiétant pour la
biodiversité merci et enfin Jean-Claude
anglar merci monsieur le Président alors
moi je mon intervention se situe dans la
continuité de ce que vient de dire
Fabien parce qu'elle était pour ne pas
laisser repartir le professeur billet
n'est-ce pas avec l'idée ici qu'on avait
pas travailler sur la sobriété foncière
et que donc sur le zan
euh je vous ais simplement indiqué que
donc quand le texte de loi est sorti la
ministre en charge du sujet madame
vargon est venue sur l'obrac n'est-ce
pas en aon et on a tester l'application
duusan dans les 10 15 ans à venir et
donc elle a dit c'est pas possible c'est
pas notre administration qui avons
proposer ce genre d'élément on a dit si
pourquoi parce que effectivement n'avait
pas été pris en compte les zones peu
denses ou très peu dens les zones de
montagnes les zones qui n'avaient pas
consommé donc d'espace qui avaient
pratiqué depuis longtemps la soueté
Forestière donc voilà donc je le dis
parce que c'est important et je pense
que au moment où on est en train de
réfléchir comment on passe de 244000
hectares au niveau national à 120000
hectares qu'il faut se partager comment
ça se passe je pense qu'il est utile
aujourd'hui que le Sénat se replonge sur
la question de l'application concrète du
je je voulais vous l'indiquer parce que
ça me semble fondamental et moi je me
félicite d'une chose voyez dans cette
loi c'est que l'État nous ait écouté sur
la mise en place du fond vert voilà qui
était un agglomérat de fond qui a
été mis en place donc il y a peu de
temps en 2023 à la main des préfets de
département pour que les collectivités
puissent agir sur le sujet c'est la
meilleure chose qui a pu être faite pour
développer l'idée de sobété foncière sur
tous les territoire premièrelement et
alors moi j'invite mes collègues dans la
réflexion qu'on peut avoir sur le
développement de l'habitat la ville sur
la ville et cetera à revoir toute la
politique de soutien à l'habitat au
privé n'est-ce pas pour arriver à cet
objectif là je pense qu'il y a des
sujets à traiter importants parce que je
pense que le fond vert a bien démarré
avec les collectivités qui se stemparé
du sujet sur la réhabilitation des
centesbours sur la renaturation et
cetera et cetera et au plus près du TER
voilà je je l'indique parce que c'est
c'est c'est très important que les
choses se passent comme ça
euh le le zan a été inventé par des gens
qui vivent en ville pardon de le dire
avec des des problèmes même d'ailleurs
ce que vous évoquez aujourd'hui surous
les sols et cetera quand on habite sur
le brac ou dans des milieux ruraux bon
les agriculteurs font ce qu'ils peuvent
ils font pas bien d'ailleurs monsieur le
professeur je vous indique qu'il y a des
appellations d'origine qui intègrent la
nature du sol et je vous invite puisque
nous sommes à Noël à manger du roquefort
l'appellation rckoffort intègre le fait
des analyses de sol qu'il faut faire
pour pouvoir bénéficier de l'appellation
je l'indiique en passant voilà c'est ce
que je voulais faire comme
remarque merci s'il n'y a pas d'autres
prise de parole je vais donner ah vas-y
alors allô à nos intervenants merci
merci Président je vais être extrêmement
extrêmement rapide mais à la suite de ce
qu'évoquai les collègues là sur sur
l'application duusan l'objectif de
sobriété foncière nous le partageons
tous nous le mettons déjà en place ceci
depuis de nombreuses années la taille
des parcelles diminue peu à peu pour
diverses raisons pas seulement écologiqu
faut pas se voiler la face avant toute
chose pour des raisons économiques mais
il est plutôt vertueux que nous l'ayons
intégré dans la loi la difficulté c'est
pas tant l'horizon mais le chemin
emprunté car aujourd'hui nous ne
connaissons pas et il est
particulièrement délicat que de pouvoir
réfléchir collectivement à la mise en
œuvre du Zéro artificialisation net et
si LEZAN présente un intérêt euh premier
écologiquement parlant c'est bien sur la
préservation des sols et de leur qualité
que vous nous avez exposé dans vos
propos liminires euh tout à l'heure
monsieur monsieur Ranjard et euh nous le
voyons au travers des différentes
interventions parfois les les
incompréhensions qui peuvent exister euh
entre nous élus euh mais aussi le monde
de la recherche et lorsque nous avons
élaboré des documents d'urbanisme qu'
s'agisse des Scotts ou des plui c'est un
binôme qui se met en place entre la
collectivité les bureaux d'études et
rares sont les bureaux d'études qui
intègrent des éléments issus de vos
travaux de recherche et dans la
perspective de la mise en œuvre duusan
comment pouvons-nous sur le moyen long
terme faire en sorte que le dialogue
entre le monde de la recherche celui que
vous représentez ce matin et les élus
puissent tisser des liens plus étroits
pour justement aussi nous guider au
mieux dans l'élaboration de documents
d'urbanisme et notamment en matière de
préservation des qualité des sols je
merercie merci je remercie encore nos
invités vous avez la parole messieurs
dames pour votre dernière question je
laisserai Philippe répondre et notamment
représenter le projet prodige parce que
c'est vraiment un projet pilote pour ce
transfert là je vais reprendre sur les
dernière question puis je vais essayer
de remonter sans en oublier sur les
panneaux
photovoltaïques oui on en implante et on
se pose la question sur la qualité du
sol et même sur ce qu'on peut faire en
terme d'usage agricole entre ces
panneaux ou sous ces panneaux en terme
d'ombrage on voit de l'écopaturage on
voit encore aussi de la production
alimentaire honnêtement aujourd'hui on
n' pas encore de recul les panneaux sont
en cours d'implantation pour la plupart
et donc les expérimentations et les
suivis d'expérimentation sont en train
de se faire euh voilà pour voir si sous
les panneaux ça se passe un peu mieux ou
un peu moins bien ou différemment de
sans panneau bon de toute façon on va
changer les conditions climatiques donc
des facto ça va influencer le sol le
couvert végétal et et obligatoirement la
biologie après est-ce que ça sera
alarmant ou non on y répondra d'ici
quelques années c'est peut-être un peu
le problème de l'implantation sans étude
d'impact a priori euh après bon voilà
c'est une vision de chercheur la
Bourgogne viticole je parlais de la
Bourgogne viticole pour l'enherbement
pas de la Bourgogne voilà c'était dans
le cas du projet covitisol la la
Bourgogne viticole est un territoire qui
enherbe peu pour des raisons de cahier
décharges et d'appellation euh une
densité de sespage qui fait que 100007
hectares c'est compliqué avec des petits
interrans de mettre une bande en herbé
qui va rentrer tout de suite en
compétition avec une vigne qui n'a pas
eu de compétiteur depuis des années des
dizaines d'années le système peut se
rééquilibrer et je vois les viticulteurs
suite à nos projets et d'autres d'autres
dynamiques aussi se mettre à enherber
malgré des difficultés techniques malgré
des baisses de rendement mais il y a une
vraie sensibilisation une sensibilité
même des agriculteurs et des
viticulteurs à ce niveau-là ce qui me
permet de rebondir aussi sur les
questions d'avant sur le monde agricole
euh oui les agriculteurs sont
sensibilisés mais ils ont peu de
possibilité de faire des analyses de sol
en tout cas physico-chimiquement ils
peuvent en faire depuis des dizaines
d'années et seulement 10 15 % des
agriculteurs le font par an ce qui est
un premier niveau d'analyse et de et de
jugement de la qualité des sols nous
notre objectif c'est d'amener des des
outils de biologie des sol de
biodiversité qui leur permettent de
compléter ces analyses pour ceux qui le
font et de les sensibiliser et de les
former je pense que derrière il y a plus
un problème de formation la sensibilité
est là mais la formation n'est pas là et
si on parle des agriculteurs on peut
parler aussi du développement agricole
qui a du mal à prendre le relais au
niveau de ces nouvelles connaissances et
de ces nouveaux outils donc tout ce qui
est chambres interprofession coopérative
institut technique tous ces organes moi
je fais partie de certains organes dans
des conseils scientifiques notamment à
l'IFV il faut que tous ces organes
s'imprègnent de ces nouvelles
connaissance comme va le faire les
politiques publiques he des échelles
territoriales et de ces nouveaux outils
et en plus aujourd'hui on est vraiment
dans une guerre de thermomètre dans une
guerre d'outils avec des choses
rationnelles et moins rationnelles c'est
pas l'objet du débat aujourd'hui mais il
y aurait beaucoup à dire et je pense
qu'il y a besoin d'une clarté sur les
outils à venir peut-être d'une
labellisation étatique ou
institutionnelle des outils de mesure de
la qualité des sols je pense que c'est
très important aujourd'hui parce qu'il y
a des choses assez peu rationnelles qui
se développent euh
oui alors ça me fait venir sur un autre
sujet on a parlé des labels tout à
l'heure des labels alimentaires avec les
planetes SCOR les écoscores où il y aura
des notions de climat des notions de
biodiversité on parle aussi des cahiers
deschargge de l'agriculture le bio
l'agriculture de conservation bon j'ai
déjà dit un peu les résultats
scientifiques ces cahiers des charges
ils sont intéressants mais ils sont sur
des obligations de moyens et c'est pas
toujours vérifié que appliquer cette cet
itinéraire technique amène au bon
résultat ou à la bonne qualité de sol je
parle pour le bio je parle pour
l'agriculture de conservation quand on
on diagnostique dans nos projets ces
mode de production on a des surprises
ils sont sans sûrement plus vertueux
mais ça ne ça ne s'exprime pas au niveau
du terrain pour des raisons diverses et
variés et donc ce qui serait peut-être
intéressant c'est d'évoluer vers des
objectifs de moyens je passe pas des des
objectifs pardon de résultats je parle
pas d'obligation de résultat parce que
ça serait coercitif mais au moins des
objectifs de résultat je sais que hve3
il réfléchit à mettre Pr préconiser
certaines mesures notamment de
microbiologie qui sont disponibles pour
juger de l'évolution d'un itinéraire
technique et du sol soumis à un
itinéraire technique ou d'une
réhabilitation de sol voilà là aussi il
y a une guerre entre la mesure et la
simulation notamment dans les labels qui
vont arriver on parle beaucoup de Big
Data aujourd'hui on a les outils on a un
certain nombre de données mais on n'est
pas capable de simuler la biodiversité
donc je me méfie assez fortement aussi
des outils de simulation qui sont
peut-être assez attractifs par des
notions de
coût de facilité d'usage mais qui
aujourd'hui pour moi ne ne sont pas
stabilisé sur le problème de Mayotte euh
manque d'eau surpopulation exploitation
des ressources c'est clair que les sols
vont empâtir aussi et vont souffrir euh
sur les systèmes tropicaux alors il y a
un rmqs tropical outre mer euh où on
commence à avoir des référentiels de la
qualité des sols physique chimique et
microbiologique et donc il sera
intéressant de voir l'évolution aussi de
la qualité de ces sols en fonction des
urgences sociales à ce niveau-là mais
c'est clair que vous avez une équation
avec beaucoup de de problématiques pour
la qualité des sols et plus largement la
qualité de
l'environnement et
enfin l'échelle territoriale je te
laisse la parole Philippe pour tout ce
qui est bien merci pour vos questions
aussi variées que il y a de variété de
sol d'abord la question des dans l'ordre
la question des des zones humide
effectivement alors comme vous le savez
ça ça ça reste une large préoccupation
française puisque on est en train de
discuter pour information moi je préside
la commission espace protégé au CNPN et
on est en train de travailler avec le le
ministère de l'Environnement sur les sur
le l'identification des zones humides
qui seraient éligibles au statut de parc
national sur territoire français et on a
on est en train de conduire l'étude
l'expertise de 11 zones humides pour
l'éligibilité et la Convention de Ramsar
donc sur la protection des des zones
humid et on on en est d'autant plus
préoccupé et je suis assez surpris de la
question parce qu'en fait on on il
existe un outil plutôt que de réinventer
ce qui qui existe déjà autant les
appliquer il existe quand même un outil
assez
fonctionnel depuis 1964 qu'on appelle le
depuis 1992 mais c'était sous d'autres
forme avant c'est ce qu'on appelle les
les schémas directeurs d'aménagement de
gestion des eos et les schémas schéma
d'aménagement de gestion des eau qui
intègrre forcément les sages et les
dages qui intègre nécessairement les
zones humides et comme vous avez un
rapport de compatibilité entre les
documents d'urbanisme et ces éléments
ben je dirais oui mais il faut renforcer
faut il faut renforcer la prise en
compte hein faut renforcer la prise en
compte et c'est vrai que pour travailler
avec certains comité local de l'eau et
cetera c'est pas toujours évident parce
que ça peut geler du point de vue
structurel beaucoup d'hectares mais dans
le même temps on tient aussi compte de
tous les éléments d'alimentation dans le
district hographique qui permet de les
d'alimenter ces zones humides et c'est
vrai que c'est parfois un peu délicat
d'avoir une gestion euh d'avoir une
gestion de de ces zones alors même qu'on
a tous les outils qui existent déjà
premier point le second très intéressant
sur la sur la notion de capital le
capital sol ou en tout cas le capital de
de de productivité et la question était
finalement comment valoriser ce capital
et j'excluraai exclusivement la question
carbone puisqu'il y a d'autres éléments
en fait j'ai un de mes collègues qui
avait qui avait utilisé un un terme un
peu particulier qu'on appelle la
transpropriation
c'est la dissociation d'usage sur un
même
objet par exemple le monument historique
vous avez les murs qui appartiennent au
propriétaires l'historisté qui
appartient à la nation et l'idée c'est
de dissocier la gestion des deux or ça
existe déjà avec les sols depuis 1902
donc actuellement c'est le 1 L 1321-2 du
code de la santé publique c'est ce qu'on
appelle les périmètres de protection des
captages on laisse entièrement la
propriété au propriétaire du sol et on a
servi la capacité de filtration du sol à
l'INT intérêt général qu'est-ce qui
interdirait d'avoir une d'avoir une
reprise de cette dissociation entre la
propriété effective du bien et
l'affectation de certaines de ces
qualités qu'on passe par des
indemnisations comme c'est le cas pour
les citudes en matière d'eau potable ou
autres élément qui permettrait alors il
faudrait trouver les outils mais ça
permettrait comme ceci de de marier les
deux intérêts à la fois l'intérêt privé
de la propriété du sol et un certain
usage et puis son asservicement à
d'autres intérêt généraux je pense qu'on
pourrait s'orienter sous ces alors que
ce soit des rémunérations indemnisation
enfin peu importe la dénomination mais
je pense ça sera intéressant de
réfléchir à cette dissociation qu'on
pourrait avoir dans ce dans ce cadre là
pour effectivement avoir une gestion
différenciée on dira du capital sol de
ce point de vue-là s'agissant ensuite de
la question de la question de de la
sovriété foncière je je n'ai pas dit que
le zan n'existait pas ne marcherait pas
et cetera et cetera je me suis je suis
simplement fondé moi comme juriste sur
les textes je sais que la sobriété
foncière fait l'objet de de beaucoup de
d'applications ce que je trouvais
criticable dans le texte et et je je
comprends parfaitement le les
préoccupations de l'Association des
mères de France et autres et autres
groupements de collectivités c'est
d'avoir essayé de trouver un texte qui
mettait en place une uniformité une
homogénéisation d'application qui était
pas tout à fait pertinente de de ce
point de de ce de ce point de vue-là
ensuite mais ça c'est plus un clin d'œil
sur la qualité des sols avec le Rockfort
en fait ce que je visais dans les labels
qui tenaient pas en compte de la qualité
des sols c'était sur l'usage effectif
parce que là dans le Rockfort on a sur
on est sur une appellation d'origine qui
tient lieu qui qui prend en compte le
comment on appelle ça la qualité
géographique notamment le solul killout
enfin tout un ensemble d'éléments mais
sur lequel on n pas un usage effectif de
production par le sol en tant que tel et
donc il y a pas d'atteinte par
l'utilisation pour les pour les BR dans
ce cadre-là donc je maintiens donc sur
le fait que on a très peu dans ce dans
ce cadre-là de d'intégration
véritablement du sol dans dans dans ces
éléments ensuite s'agissant du dialogue
entre les élus à la recherche je prends
l'idée que l'on a avec développé dans le
cadre du projet prodige à Dijon qui est
porté d'abord est ce qui montre bien le
lien par le Grand Dijon c'està-dire avec
Françis bamen sur cette question ce qui
donc c'est été porté et voulu par le
Grand Dijon d'accompagner la recherche
sur euh la mise en place de dispositifs
expérimentaux ce qui montre bien qu'on a
le lien on en lien permanent en lien
permanent avec eux et alors je ne sais
plus comment va vont être transposés les
résultats scientifiques durs sur le plan
juridique nous on est en train de
produire un livret explicatif un livret
d'accompagnement des élus sur comment
mieux utiliser le sol dans les
politiques d'urbanisme je te laisse
compléter sur l'autre élément bah tout
simplement on fait des rendus aux
politiques publiques et et aux élus des
résultats qu'on obtient sur la qualité
des sols alors là avantage aussi du
projet prodige c'est qu'on a fait les
sols urbains donc les sols à l'intérieur
de la ville avec des questions
d'aménagement urbain et puis bien sûr
les sols périurbains et ruraux avec des
questions plutôt agricole et donc on on
fait des des rendus qui vont avoir lieu
d'ailleurs cette année qui sont assez
conséquents à organisés avec les élus
avec les agriculteurs avec tous les
organes en fait qui sont intéressés par
la qualité des sols après les sorties en
terme d'application d'intégration dans
des scottes dans des PLU dans le foncier
c'est des choses qui sont à travailler
je pense c'est pas mon domaine hein mais
en tout cas nous on essaie de de
rationaliser le plus possible et de
rendre très opérationnel la notion de
mesure et on en fait des diagnostics
parce que c'est important la mesure elle
est scientifique le diagnostic il est
opérationnel et on est dans cet état-là
et quand on fait je recite et covitisol
quand on va devant les viticulteurs ou
plus largement les agriculteurs il faut
un diagnostic il faut pas leur parler
recherche Scien moyenne écart type il
faut un diagnostic avec trois couleurs
parce que il faut des choses
opérationnelles comme vous allez voir
vos labels alimentaires aussi avec
différentes couleurs et VO voilà il faut
que ça soit très facile à interpréter et
au regard de ces pratiques et de la
modification des usages pardon je
rajouterai chaque fois qu'on a des
réunion des parties prenantes tous les
partenaires sont présents et notamment
les partenaires des collectivités
locales ce qui montre bien l'intérêt
très fort qu'il porte au projet au-delà
de l'aspect strrictement politique he il
y a quand même un côté très opérationnel
qui a été recherché d'ailleurs dans ce
cadre
là ce qui permet de stimuler énormément
la recherche aussi c'est-à-dire que la
recherche elle elle est elle est comme
tout organe elle a l'habitude de de
fonctionner d' unee certaine façon là de
faire une production de connaissances
nouvelles que l'on rend opérationnelle
et que l'on transfère dans un lapse de
temps relativement court ça booste un
peu un système de recherche qui qui
devient finalisé VO voilà alimentant les
politiques publiques donc c'est aussi
dynamique dans les deux
sens est-ce que nos intervenants on
répondu à toutes les questions qu'il y
aurait des questions qui étaient
[Musique]
oubliées oublé aux
questions
non est-ce que notre invité en visio
veut ajouter quelque chose Monsieur
dekerur très bien et bien moi je tiens
franchement à vous remercier toutes et
tous pour avoir effectivement répondu à
notre invitation et à cette table ronde
je crois que c'est c'est un sujet euh
comme vous avez pu le voir à travers le
de nombreuses questions qui est un sujet
important euh qui concerne effectivement
euh ben l'avenir et qui concerne nos
sols et leur protection de nos sols et
merci euh je crois que effectivement le
travail qui doit être fait c'est un
c'est un travail en commun euh c'est pas
comme l'a dit le représentant de
l'Association des MRES de ruraux de
France on ne doit pas opposer euh les
villes mais je crois qu'on doit avoir un
regard euh euh bien évident et bien
particulier sur l'ensemble de de de de
notre territoire qu' soit d'ailleurs euh
euh les territoire d'outrem également on
a notre collègue qui nous l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure merci pour pour vos
intervention merci pour avoir participé
à cette table ronde et et puis nous
allons maintenant pour celles et ceux
qui le veulent nous rendre sur le
terrain dans le jardin du Luxembourg je
vous
remercie